Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, bis dahin, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
So, ich hör aus, Teams hat Sound umgestellt, KegWaite. Guckt euch das mal an, so ein Schrottprogramm, lull.
Leute, sagt man eigentlich noch afk-klo? Ist das noch, ist das noch, ist afk-klo noch gebräuchliche Redewendung im deutschen MMO Jagor?
Ja, safe, exzellent. Nee, hätte ja sein können, dass man heute irgendwas anderes sagt. Heute sagt man ja auch, ich küss deine Augen oder so komisches Zeug.
Was gibt's aber? Richtig lost, äh, da mag's wieder. Richtig lost fühl ich. Und dann werden die Augen geküsst oder, genau.
Boomer versucht sich in Jugendsprache. Huge Pains Champ.
Leute, ich hab gesehen, dass Anfang April, nee Schwachsinn, Februar, aber jetzt ein Fix rausgekommen ist für Nextcloud.
Und ihr wisst, ich bin echt kein Nextcloud-Fan, aber ich hab mir gedacht, ich hab jetzt ein paar Tage nicht gestreamt, weil ich war echt beschäftigt.
Wir gucken uns das einfach noch mal an und Pains Champen zusammen.
Pains Champen, ihr wisst, ich mag Nextcloud nicht. Also das kann durchaus sein, also wenn ihr, wenn ihr großer Nextcloud-Fan seid, dann ist das durchaus möglich, dass ihr euch aufregen müsst in diesem Stream.
Nee, Rust-Backend, war das nicht, war das nicht owncloud, die irgendwas neu programmiert haben? Aber auch nicht in Rust, oder?
Oder haben die was in Rust neu programmiert? Ich weiß nicht. Ich blick dann immer durch, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich schreibe morgen Englisch, Abi, was fällt dir ein zu streamen? We are all sitting in one boat. Easy win.
So, ich muss jetzt mal eine andere Musik anmachen.
Erst mal andere Musik. Im Zweifel haben wir wieder Mario Kart. Mario Kart geht immer. Was haben wir denn hier?
Yoshi singing, oh nee, das ist nervig.
Excellent.
Was machen wir jetzt? Yoshi.
Ne, das ist mir zu anstrengend auch.
So, ich mach wieder Mario Kart. Mario Kart geht eigentlich immer.
Ich finde Mario Kart ist so die beste Arbeitsmusik. Ich hab auch total oft, wenn ich Sachen programmiere, habe ich Mario Kart Musik an.
Doch, der SYNC ist Rust. Ach echt? Ja gut, der SYNC, der hat ja auch richtig Probleme gemacht vorher.
Hallo Max, wenn ich eine Million zahle, zeigst du dann dein Gesicht? Ja, wenn du eine Million an mich zahlst, dann schon.
An mich und Euro. Keine indischen Rupien.
Leute, ich hab mir in Indien YouTube Premium gekauft.
India. Ich kann immer mal schreiben.
Virus-BLN. Oder vielleicht ist es auch Virus-BLN, man weiß es nicht. Dankeschön für vier Monate Subscription.
Genau, ich hab mir nämlich hier, guck mal, für 399 indische Rupien, was auch immer ein Screen bedeuten soll, ich weiß es nicht,
hab ich mir das gekauft, das kostet ungefähr 4,40 Euro. 4,40 Euro, drei Monate YouTube Premium, richtig poggers.
Wisst ihr was ich in zu meiner Zeit immer richtig cringe fand? Wahrscheinlich was die Leute heute cringe finden, wenn ich sage richtig poggers.
Früher haben die Leute gesagt, richtig pornoes, das fand ich immer richtig cringe. Painschamp. Hab ich nie gesagt.
Findet ihr das auch, Painschamp-Chat? Was sagt ihr, ist pornoes, ist das Painschamp oder geht das?
Schon Bock auf den neuen Battlefield Teil? Naja, man weiß ja nichts.
Einzige Sache, die ich jetzt gelesen hab von Battlefield 6 ist, dass es wohl keine Kampagne gibt. Wenn ich jetzt noch richtig schreiben will, soll es wohl keine Kampagne geben, hab ich gelesen, genau.
Oh, Flashbang. Ah, yes, schon gleich viel besser. Aber mal im Ernst, mich juckt es auch nicht, weil ehrlich gesagt, die einzige Kampagne, die ich gut fand,
jetzt mal Real Talk versuch, die einzige Battlefield Kampagne, die ich wirklich uneingeschränkt empfehlen kann, ist Bad Company 1.
Bad Company 2 war schon so halbe halbe. Das hatte coole Momente, aber war nicht mehr so dieses Yolo Battlefield 1.
Ich sag euch, Kampagne Bad Company 1 ist immer noch eins der besten. Ja, Console Only, aber gut, das ändert ja nichts an der Qualität der Kampagne. Die war wirklich gut.
Nee, enlisted hab ich noch nicht ausprobiert. Ich wollte es runterladen letztens.
BC 1 Kampagne ist echt gut. Ich würd die sogar mal Just for Fun on Stream spielen, aber die Grafik ist heute so Painschamp-ig und ich müsste mit dem Xbox Controller spielen.
So, die Kampagne von Battlefield, äh, von BC 2 fand ich ganz in Ordnung. Battlefield 3 fand ich ja persönlich relativ gut.
Aber nur, aber nur, wenn man nicht so genau hingeguckt hat. Weil Battlefield 3 war ziemlich kaputt in der Kampagne.
Ja, da waren Levels teilweise, zur Hälfte nicht da. Man konnte, man konnte Straßen lang laufen, wo Löcher drin waren, wo man unter die Map konnte und so.
Also, Battlefield 3 Kampagne war echt richtig kaputt. Kannst du dir eine Million in Raten zahlen? Ja, ja, kannst du auch machen, kannst du auch machen.
Ich würd sagen, wir fangen mal mit einer Anzahlung von 250.000 an und dann würd ich sagen, können wir ein bisschen runtergehen, ja. Schon okay.
Du hast die Battlefield Kampagne geprägt. Ja, wie gesagt, Battlefield 3 durfte man nicht zu genau hingucken, wenn man die Battlefield 3 Kampagne einfach nur YOLO gerade ausgespielt hat.
Wie es gedacht war, fand ich die echt nicht schlecht.
Auch wenn die merkwürdige, ja, merkwürdige Erzählweise hatte, mit teilweise... Also, muss ich jetzt mal ein bisschen ausholen.
In der Battlefield 3 Kampagne hatten sie mehrere Charaktere. Auf Ami-Seite, auf Kokona-Seite, auf Commodore-Seite.
Und da gibt's eine Mission, Achtung, Spoiler, Battlefield 3 Kampagne, Spoiler, da gibt's eine Singleplayer-Mission, wo man die Russen zum ersten Mal spielt.
Und dann stirbt irgendein Russe in der Kampagne und die tun so, als wäre das voll schlimm.
Das Problem ist, dass es die erste Mission ist, wo dieser Charakter drin vorkommt und du kehrst absolut nicht, der Charakter geht im Marsch vorbei.
Und später gibt's Missionen, die spielen davor, da lebt der Charakter wieder und da lernt man den Charakter, also total bescheuert gemacht.
Also das hätte man deutlich sinniger erledigen können.
Aber gut, Battlefield Kampagne, also das wollen sie jetzt anscheinend streichen, das hab ich gelesen.
Ist es aber auch alles nur Leak und nicht offiziell und sonst wie.
Aber ich hab das übrigens auch schon mal in einem Video gesagt, oder bin ich mir zumindest sicher, und auch schon öfters im Stream,
wo ich gesagt hab, das wäre gar keine schlechte Idee, die Kampagne zu streichen.
Oder ich weiß nicht, ob ich gesagt hab, ich gehe von aus, weil ich kann von viel ausgehen, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Aber ich halte das für keine schlechte Idee, die Kampagne zu streichen.
Weil mal ganz im Ernst, die Kampagne fand ich gerade, also ab Battlefield 4 fand ich die total unsinnig.
Battlefield 4, jetzt mal, hatte jemand von euch das Problem, dass er in Battlefield 4, Emotion Sickness ist zu viel gesagt,
aber dass er in der Kampagne leichtes Unwohlsein hatte, in der Battlefield 4 Kampagne, weil dort so viel Blur-Effekte, Verschiebungsdinger und Gewackel war.
Das war das erste oder einzige Spiel, Battlefield 4 in einer Singleplayer-Kampagne, wo ich das jemals hatte, wo es mir so ein bisschen unwohl beim Spielen war,
weil das so, weil das so, so shaky shaky alles war.
Man kann den Erko von den AirTags wechseln, ja hab ich schon gelesen.
So, und deswegen brauch ich so Kampagnen in der Richtung nicht.
So, was ist ein AirTag? Das ist ein Bluetooth-Beacon, BLE-Teil von Bluetooth Low Energy, Teil von Apple.
Was 29 Euro kostet.
Sorry, 35 Euro, 29 Dollar.
Wer hätte denken können, dass das hier annehmbare Preise hätte, ja.
Ich mach mal kurz mal eine V-M an.
Hab gehört, die bauen ein mobiles Battlefield, das hab ich nicht gehört, aber das...
Oh, wollen wir heute Mowbuntu verwenden? Nee, wollen wir nicht.
Was bringt das? Da kannst du beispielsweise einen Schlüssel mitsuchen.
Ich benutze sowas auch schon, aber vom anderen Hersteller, das ist tatsächlich ganz praktisch.
Da kann man seinen Schlüssel mitsuchen oder man kann Presence Detection machen.
Wenn man das zum Beispiel am Schlüsselbund hat, da kann man mit einer App auslösen, dass der Schlüssel klingelt.
Oder umgedreht, wenn man den Schlüssel mit rausnimmt, kann man den Schlüssel auslösen,
wenn man den Schlüssel mit rausnimmt, kann man beispielsweise mit einem Raspberry Pi oder einem ESP scannen, ob dieses Beacon in der Nähe ist.
Also sprich, da kann man dann auch erkennen, okay, der Schlüssel ist nicht mehr in der Wohnung und sowas.
Ist nice, wie gesagt, ich verwende so Teil-Tags schon eine Weile.
Mal gucken, wie das mit den Apple-Dingern wird.
Erst mal starten, starte das verdammte Spiel.
Äh, gibt es eigentlich einen Open Source-Hardware-Hersteller von den Teilen?
Hm...
Es gab mal Happy Bubbles, ich glaube, das gibt es nicht mehr.
Also ich meine, so einen Beacon ist easy as fuck selbst zu machen, ja.
Das Problem ist halt, dass es, ähm...
...einem Beacon in der Nähe ist.
Das Problem ist halt energiesparend.
Ja, also natürlich, du kannst einen ESP dranhängen, aber das braucht zu viel, auch im Stand-By.
Neue Warzone-Map, ja, habe ich gelesen, ich habe gelesen, die Server sind übelst instabil.
Ansonsten, ich habe gelesen, die Server sind übelst instabil.
Ansonsten, wie gesagt, ich habe seit ein paar Monaten keinen Warzone mehr gespielt,
hat mich auch nicht großartig mehr gejuckt.
Wenn Battlefield ein Battle Royale hat, werde ich mir den auf jeden Fall angucken.
Wobei es mir ja persönlich, also nur mir persönlich, ich weiß, dass es die meisten Leute anders sehen,
aber mir persönlich wäre ja am liebsten, rein Gameplay-technisch,
sie scheißen auf Battle Royale und alle Trends der letzten Jahre
und machen ein gutes Battlefield mit Rush und Conquest, aber das wird nicht passieren.
Weil die gucken rüber zu Warzone, wisst ihr was die Leute bei EA machen?
Die gucken rüber zu Warzone und sehen das hier.
Und wenn die das hier sehen, dann sagen sie, das machen wir auch.
Sag ich's, danke schön für vier Monate. Subscription.
Was die... das hab ich bei Heise gelesen heute Morgen, ja, aber ich hab's mir nicht angeguckt, den Artikel.
Zeig mal her.
Bugs mit Vorsatz. University of Minnesota von Linux Kernel mit...
What? Warum?
Ist Next Cloud jetzt Payne's Champ oder nicht? Ich vermute mal, dass es Payne's Champ ist.
Immer noch. Die letzten Versionen waren alle Payne's Champ-Pickst.
Was sag ich, die Steigerung von Payne's Champ?
Payne's Champ? Payne's Champiger am Payne's Champicksten?
So, was sagen die denn?
Oliusgirls do not like being experimented on. Also, was haben sie gemacht?
Diese früheren Beiträge seien offensichtlich in böser Absicht und mit dem Vorsatz Probleme zu verursachen vermittelt worden.
Okay, warum? Warum?
Dieses Projekt ist super für akkubetriebene ESP's. Okay, gucken wir uns gleich mal an.
Poff.
31 Sterne, ist das von dir?
Ja, machst du Werbung für eigene Sachen? Nicht, dass ich damit Probleme hätte, kannst du ruhig machen.
So.
Also, was haben die denn gemacht?
Bewusster Schwachstellen einbau. Offenbar hat eine Gruppe von Studenten wiederholt fehlerhafte Patches.
Ja, aber warum?
Mit voller Absicht, wie der Inhalt einer aktuellen Forschungsarbeit.
Ja, okay. Das ist natürlich, also, das könnte auch vorgeschoben sein, ne?
Das könnte auch vorgeschoben sein. Man könnte auch gesagt haben, fuck, die haben uns erwischt.
Oder irgendwas und sagt, ja, ja, Moment, Moment, Moment, wir haben da noch so eine Arbeit in der Hinterhand.
Das war nur, das war rein auswischend zu wissenschaftlichen Zwecken.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne. Also nichts. Wir sind nicht unfähig oder so. Rein auswischend zu wissenschaftlichen Zwecken.
Werbung für eigene Sachen. Bitbattle auf Steam anschauen. Schick mal einen Link.
Die Arbeit untersucht die Unsicherheit von, also, das müssen wir nicht untersuchen.
Habt ihr das mit PHP mitgekriegt? PHP hat ja das gleiche Problem letztens gehabt.
Die hatten bei PHP, hatten die einen Commit drinne. Ist jetzt kein Scherz, ne?
Es wurde, also der Git Server von PHP, oder was, das Git Repo von PHP, wurde gehackermant.
Und dort wurde ein Code eingeschlossen, der, also wenn man PHP im Backend laufen lässt
und einen Header mit, also ich muss das anders erklären.
Also, wenn man PHP im Backend laufen hat und das ist eine PHP Version mit diesen Patches
und jemand schickt einen Request, eine Anfrage mit einem Browser an den PHP Server in eurem Backend
und der Header hat, glaub ich, was musste im Header stehen?
So was musste, glaub ich, im Header stehen.
Wenn so was im Header stand, dann wurde alles weitere da hinten auf dem Server executed.
Also sprich, es musste ein HTTP Header gesetzt sein, der mit, ich glaub, Cerodium oder irgendwie so anfängt.
Ne, Cerodium, Cerodium, Cerodium war es, genau.
So, das musste im Header stehen und alles, was dann dahinter steht, zum Beispiel auch exec-rm-rf-slash
wurde dann auf dem Server ausgeführt.
Wer hat denn Spaß gemercht? Der Git, das Git Repo von PHP wurde gehackermant.
Man sieht das übrigens noch auf GitHub.
Mal gucken, ob man das, mal gucken, ich versuch's euch mal zu zeigen.
GitHub, PHP, das Shit Repo, genau.
Die sind jetzt nämlich gewechselt, die sind jetzt nämlich gewechselt von ihrem eigenen Repo auf GitHub.
Sorry, sorry.
Shit Hub, natürlich.
Und wir müssen mal gucken, ob wir das Comment noch finden.
Ich hab mir da ein bisschen was zu angeguckt und irgendjemand hat einen Comment rein.
Wir gucken uns das jetzt zusammen an.
Ich zeige euch jetzt, wo das drinsteht.
Wir müssen einen Revert finden, wir brauchen einen Revert.
Revert, Revert, Revert.
Die haben das nämlich revertet und dann hat's wieder einer eingecheckt.
Wir suchen einfach mal nach einem Revert.
Wenn wir ein Revert finden, haben wir auch das Comment.
Brezelsnacker, woher hast du das jetzt so schnell?
Von wann ist es 26 Tage?
Vor 26 Tage, fix Taipo, fix Taipo.
Fix Taipo, ist natürlich beste, ja.
Okay, wir müssen eine ganze Ecke zurück.
Ich zeige es euch, das ist wirklich aus dem Repo.
Ich mache jetzt nicht einfach den Link auf.
Kann man hier nicht einfach mehr einblenden?
Doch, doch, doch, das wurde gemerged, das wurde gemerged.
Aber es kam nicht in den Release rein.
Hier, da ist es, da ist es, PHP Version.
Also, das ist das erste fix Taipo.
Wir gucken uns das jetzt zusammen an, also.
Was da eingecheckt wurde, ist also von irgendeinem Typ.
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht, ob das der Hacker-Man ist
oder ob dem sein Account kompromittiert wurde oder sonst was.
Vor allem auch das geile ist, SkipCI, also sprich,
wir haben auch noch die kompletten Tests übersprungen.
Hey, weißt du, ob man für die PS4 einen Bot schreiben kann?
Der verhindert, dass man wegen afgekickt wird.
Weißt du, was der beste Bot ist, um afgekickt zu werden?
Einfach den Controller einklemmen
oder automatisch einen Knopf drücken lassen alle paar Sekunden von irgendwas.
Aber ich würde den Stick einklemmen im Sofa,
sodass du dich permanent im Kreis drehst, easy.
Einfach den Stick einklemmen vom Controller.
Five-Hat-Lösung.
Gummibot um die Sticks.
Das funktioniert nicht mehr.
Dann hol dir irgend so ein Cronos-Device-Ding oder so
und mach einen Skript, was einen Knopf drückt.
So, also wir gucken uns jetzt mal,
wir gucken uns jetzt mal diese PAP-Geschichten an.
Also das hier ist das Comment, was eingecheckt wurde.
Und jetzt passt mal auf, was die da eingecheckt haben.
Hier, hier geht's schon los.
Hier geht's schon los, ne?
Also musst du aufpassen, man sieht,
da taucht dieses Wort immer mal wieder drin auf.
Und ich hab keine Ahnung von PAP,
aber ich kann es so ungefähr lesen, ja?
So, also.
Oh, das siehst du.
Genau.
This line executes PHP-Code
from within the user-agent PAP-Header.
Also, äh, HTTP-Header.
Also sprich, wenn der HTTP-Header mit Serodium startet,
dann führt das PHP alles aus, was dahinter steht.
Das ist C und nicht PAP.
Ja, und?
Ach so, das ist C und nicht PAP.
Ja, und? Ach so, du meinst, ja.
Ich mein, ich hab keine Ahnung im PAP-Quellcode.
Ich blick da nicht durch,
was da jetzt an welchen Stellen genau passiert.
Na, das ist eindeutig C, das stimmt.
Ich wusste beidem gar nicht, dass PAP ein C ist,
aber gut, passt ja.
Genau, und zumindest, hier wird alles ausgeführt.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob man das groß machen kann.
Wir gucken jetzt mal den PAP-Sourcecode.
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt hier.
S-Files Brose.
Moment.
Zack, wie ging das nochmal?
Ob man sich nicht hier irgendwie...
Ah ja, noch, View-File.
Also es ist ein wenig groß.
Ah, so ein 1500-Zeilen-C-File, da blickt man natürlich schon noch durch.
Genau, das ist der eigentliche Code,
der dafür sorgt, dass HTTP-Header, wo das drinne steht,
alles weitere ausgeführt wird.
Also, lass mal kurz gucken, ob wir da durchblicken.
Das ist irgendwelche PAP-internen Geschichten.
Gucken, ob das ein Array ist.
Blablabla.
Okay, der User-Agent-Header.
Warum ist der Agent übrigens doppelt T?
Weiß ich nicht.
So, User-Agent-Header.
Und dann wird geguckt,
wenn...
Wahrscheinlich der Header.
Wenn der User-Agent-Header...
damit startet.
So, und das hier ist das eigentliche Ding.
Also, ich gehe mal davon aus,
dass Cent-Eval-String im Prinzip nichts anderes macht
wie einen String einfach eins zu eins durch den PAP-Interpreter zu schicken.
Eines Tages werde ich Hokage...
Jetzt kommen die da Ruto-Leute hier auch an Start.
Ja, hast mich gefunden.
Exzellent, Feind.
Also, ich vermute mal, dass das hier eine Funktion ist,
die jeglichen String-Content durch den PAP-Interpreter jagt.
Und ich meine, damit kannst du dann alles machen.
Also, lässt deinen User-Agent-Header mit Zerodium anfangen
und danach schickst du ihn in rm-rf mit.
Oder noch besser,
Datenbank-Dump an dein Upload bei dir auf Pastebin.
So, also das ist ziemlicher Fail, was die da haben.
So, und das wurde gemerged.
Danach hat es jemand reverted.
Danach haben sie es wieder weggemacht.
Haben gesagt,
Compromised-Git-Account.
LOL-WTF.
By the way, da siehst du, dass die PAP-Leute oldschool sind.
Die schreiben noch LOL.
Heutzutage wäre es auf jeden Fall LUL.
Und um nicht zu sagen LULW,
weil wir uns ja prinzipiell alle einig sind,
dass LULW besser ist als CACW.
Und die richtigen Hacker haben jetzt LEL geschrieben. LEL.
Kennt ihr mal noch die Zeiten, wo man LEL geschrieben hat?
Wo man LULW zu Mainstream war. LEL.
Das waren so ICQ-Zeiten. LEL.
Das war es richtig eingeblieben eigentlich.
So, danach
wurde der revert wieder reverted.
Jetzt ist es wieder drin.
Abitare Code Injection für HTTP-Header.
Genau.
Ja, ist natürlich geil.
Mailing-Liste.
Leute, da sind noch mehr Boomer als ich.
Die schreiben nicht nur LOL.
Die verwenden auch Mailing-Listen.
So, und jetzt
ist es wieder klar,
die verwenden auch mailinglisten so und danach wird das ganze das revert wird also der revert
was reverted wurde wird wieder reverted und es ist wieder weg und das war das war die story
aber daran sieht man das ist echt ein problem das ist wirklich ein problem gerade bei solchen
open source projekten wo mittlerweile total viele leute kontributen wo das ganze auch
mittlerweile total undurchsichtig wird wenn einer der main contributors oder einer zumindest mit
direktem access auf das git repo sein account kompromittiert ist da kannst du da einfach
sachen drin verstecken und je nachdem wie gut das gemacht ist wird mich nicht wundern wenn in
manchen projekten sachen in dieser richtung schlummern von denen man noch gar nichts weiß
vollkommen nicht pro 14 monat dankeschön für den sub exzellente subscription
übrigens morgen habe ich noch mal einen termin mit hetzner vielleicht kriegen wir das sponsoring
video am wochenende sogar schon online und danach im stream mal gucken wir mal gucken ob wir uns
morgen auf irgendwie stonks money eilen können video habe ich schon aufgenommen ja ich weiß ich
weiß ich weiß der git server wurde hacker man aber das ist prinzipiell ja auch ein problem bei
repos die auf github sind also wenn du maintainer bist oder wenn du wenn du direkt master push access
hast dann muss nicht der git server gehackt werden sondern es reicht der github account deswegen mich
wird nicht wundern wenn in manchen repos die ein oder anderen sachen schlummern von denen man noch
gar nichts weiß choose my name dann ist die kacke am dampfen hast du voll und ganz recht weil man
hat ja schon letztens wieder gesehen habt ihr das ihr habt das bestimmt mit dem ruby mit dem ruby
gem mitbekommen es gab einen ruby gem was irgendwie auch in der 30 milliaren abhängigkeiten hat und
irgendeiner hat die lizenz geändert oder sogar die published oder so ich weiß nicht mehr genau ich
glaube die lizenz hat sich geändert die version wurde zurückgezogen das hat irgendwie gott und
die welt an ruby projekten kaputt gemacht klar man kann jetzt sagen who cares ruby projekte im
jahr 2021 aber gibt es halt noch genug und man könnte auch sagen who cares pp projekte aber mal
ehrlich wie der kabum früher gesagt eine hand aufs herz können ihr euch vorstellen wie viel
seiten noch auf php laufen und wahrscheinlich in zukunft noch weiter auf php laufen werden und
und neuen php programmiert werden das halbe internet gefühlt ist immer noch php und man
muss ja auch mal eine lance brechen für php an der stelle so kacke ist php gar nicht bei mir
ist das letzte mal php schon ein bisschen her aber ich habe mit da war noch relativ neu mal was
gemacht ich muss sagen ich fand das eigentlich ganz angenehm ja und dazu kommt und dazu kommt das
ist nämlich richtig was die killer kartoffel geschrieben hat dass jeder 0815 billig hauster
php hat und eine maya sql datenbank oder maria db also egal welchen hauster ihr hingeht auch wenn
ihr zu diesem billig hauster geht wo ich mal den life den lifetime vm gekauft habe der hat pv pvp
aber der hat php und maya sql am start ihr könnt natürlich auch ich mache jetzt schon mal pre
sellout ihr könnt euch natürlich auch bei hetsenen server mieten in der cloud für 2 euro 80 oder so im
monat und da euer eigenes zeug drauf machen aber heute bin ich auch nicht gesponsert bei hetsen
ihr könnt natürlich auch zu jedem anderen cloud anbieter gehen aber hetsener ist preis
leistungsmäßig schon ganz ok schon angefangen nö machen wir jetzt aber wir machen es einfach
im docker docker konti container stellts nex cloud 80 prozent rabatt mit coach tells also
wenn es interessiert wollt ihr wissen wie viel rabatt ihr mit dem max fps hetsener code bekommt
wahrscheinlich wollt ihr wissen post jam gar keinen aber ihr bekommt was anderes ihr bekommt
20 euro oder 30 euro ich bin nicht ganz sicher ganz sicher 20 oder 30 euro cloud gut haben für
für glaub drei monate ich meine das ist nicht schlecht das ist nicht schlecht ich meine davon
kann davon kann man immerhin drei monate in der mittelklasse mittelklasse naja untere mittelklasse
server wann denn ja gut vielleicht morgen je nachdem ob ich mir mit denen einig werde
hetsener pricing ich kann ich kann echt nicht schreiben leute so wenn ihr mal guckt was das
kostet also für die ihr könnt drei monate lang quasi schon mal hier ist doch nicht verkehrt
den da könnt ihr drei monate betreiben da kann man sich da nicht beschweren mehrfach
einlösbar wahrscheinlich nicht wahrscheinlich mussten euren account machen dann ist mehrfach
einlösbar ich gehe mal davon aus dass das account gebunden ist also wie beimauer genau
wie beimauer den habe ich übrigens auch erwähnt als ich mit hetsener telefoniert habe ich
satte ich habe gesehen der bauer hat auch bei euch habe ich am letztes beim bauer video
gesehen dass der sponsoring mit euch gemacht hat so ein video placement können wir gerne
auch mal zum zum kennenlernen machen habe ich den vorgeschlagen und das fanden sie
ganz gut backup kostet aber extra naja gut was willst du kannst du dir alles umsonst
haben aber außerdem wir brauchen backup backup ist ja nur wirklich outdated she baited overrated
macht jemand ernsthaft backups von euch das ist wie das ist wie gut backups leute könnt
mir das erzählen weicheier alter hier mit backups das ist wie das ist wie guter code
der sich selbst dokumentiert gut aufgesetzte surfer gehen nicht kaputt also nachdem wir
ja alle absolut poggers defops big brain admins sind sind unsere surfer selbstverständlich
so gut aufgesetzt dass sie prinzipiell nicht kaputt gehen ergo ist backup nur zeit und
geldverschwendung so sieht es aus jetzt haben wir die wichtigen fragen schon mal je t'a
ok ich muss mir mal das aktuell nächste dot docker image raussuchen übrigens habt ihr
schon unseren habe habe ich euch schon uns super agilen chat gezeigt von der arme leute
ich sehe schon das wird heute wieder nix von der arbeit gezeigt da wollte ich nämlich
noch was zu erzählen und zwar wir hatten heute übrigens ich war wieder an der frischen
luft ob es ob es euch vorstellen könnt oder nicht monka es frische luft guck mal wenn
man da genau guckt leute wenn man genau guckt erkennt ihr die kühe erkennt die kühe das
hier kommt mal da kühe excellent ku pixel hier hinten ja massive ku pixel da die erkennt
man besser windows background ja sieht ein bisschen so aus und ich sage euch so so so
so gerne ich ja mittlerweile so naturshells habe das stinkt schon ganz schön wenn die
da dünger gedüngt haben vielleicht spiegele ich mich auch in den ku augen da hinten irgendwo
ob ich glaube da spiegele ich mich gerade irgendwo high quality camera das ist das iphone xr oder
war mal einfach ich kann es immer nicht mehr kapitän xr der chat weiß das chat ich habe
nix eher oder übrigens mal postchamp mal postchamp ich habe eine mail bekommen vorgestern
dass mein iphone ausgetauscht wird was ist denn das was ist gibt es schon ein neueres
als das xr von der gleichen preiskategorie was ist das nächste was kommt nach dem xr
zwölfer 11 in den se nicht sehr bescheuert xr durch den se zu ersetzen wahrscheinlich
eine zwölfer oder so mal gucken ich bin mal gespannt was die machen dann habe ich hier
8k auflösung oder was auch immer warum habe ich jetzt twitter aufgemacht was wollte ich
euch dann zeigen hier genau heute richtig big brain hyper cloud native agilen chat auf der
arbeit gehabt hat jemand schon mal sachen nach nach er kopiert da gibt es so ein tool
von microsoft für nennt sich ads copy und das hat ein problem das hat ein problem das
kackt ab weil es zu viel speicher zu viel speicher braucht so und jetzt zeige ich euch
mal big brain microsoft time wirklich massive brain microsoft time da lacht da lacht ihr
euch kaputt ads copy out of memory so moment moment moment jetzt jetzt kommt jetzt kommt
jetzt kommt jetzt kommt also es hat hier so einen typ reported dass das out of memory
geht wenn da wenn wenn man viele dateien hat so und dann haben die gesagt es gibt jetzt
eine environment variable es gibt jetzt ads copy buffer gb das ist eine environment variable
die kann man setzen dass es nicht out of memory geht und jetzt passt mal auf
ist es nicht geil ist es nicht genial ist es nicht top
microsoft sich da überlegt hat diesen scheiß parameter eingeführt und ein
jahr später ist es kaputt gegangen und es interessiert keine sau ich habe mich heute
morgens so weg gepisst als ich das gesehen habe und daraufhin hatten wir halt die super
geile cloud big brain agile cloud idea wir packen das ganze einfach in den docker container
mit ram beschränkung weil weil weil die offizielle beschreibung von diesem von diesem
variable ist also das hier wissen wir dass es nicht funktioniert ja aber das hier ist
das interessante die fall ist based on der machine size ram würde ich sagen das bedeutet
wenn man das in dem docker container startet und dort den ram beschränkt auf sagen wir
8 oder 16 g dann ist halt der default schon kleiner ich weiß nicht ob es der kollege
heute noch ausprobiert hat auf der arbeit aber microsoft taktik ist schon wieder geil
oder da muss ich echt kacken heute morgen als ich das gelesen habe ok so jetzt kommen
wir mal zu next cloud jetzt hier ernsthaft kein spaß mehr ok next cloud docker hub wo
sind wir ich hab mich echt gefreut hab gesagt hier hast du schon auf github gesehen es gibt
dann kommando es gibt eine variable für da macht es nicht mehr dann kommt dann gucken
wir auf github nach uns erste issue was wir finden ist variablen wird ignoriert
absolute frecher dass du heute erst was zu next cloud machst ich hab meine projekt docker
dazu ich mag next cloud nicht ich hab schon öfters was mit next cloud hier im stream
gemacht ich bin absolut kein next cloud fern und mal gucken ob sich das heute ändert spoiler
ich glaube nicht aber aber schau mal mal so next cloud 19 quake ach nee hier next cloud
verwirrt mich bei docker geschichten immer weil weil die haben so viele images ich weiß
überhaupt nicht was für ein image ist da verwenden soll soll ich das mit apache verwenden
soll ich das mit mit alt das lp das alpine alpine linux image verwenden soll ich das
wenn das glaube ich ubuntu was ist da was gibt es eine gute alternative ja da bin ich
auch noch auf der suche aber nachdem ich ja nur feinzünk und kalender verwende von next
cloud da gibt es ein paar alternativen und das wollte ich demnächst auch mal ausprobieren
kennst du next cloud mit docker compose so betreibe ich das aktuell bei mir daheim ja
aber ich bin wie gesagt kein next cloud kein next cloud fan und ich würde es gern ablösen
deswegen gucken wir uns demnächst auch ein paar next cloud alternativen an also sync
thing gefällt mir ganz gut was ich bisher gesehen habe rein für filesync und ich muss
mal ein bisschen rumgucken so also nee augencloud wäre ich jetzt jetzt ja pest mit cholera
austauschen alter next cloud zu augencloud so ähm welches welches image ist denn hier
ok wir starten einfach next cloud einfach next cloud starten easy so also wir verwenden
nicht das pod mapping wir verwenden network oh nee ich kann ja mal nicht merken wie das
wie das was net network mode moment warum habe ich kein docker auto kommt doch habe
ich d ja d ist im hintergrund network network gleich host excellent also wenn man das bei
an gibt dann bindet er sich an die host ip und man macht da kein komisches docker proxy
geschiss weil ich will dann auch vom anderen rechner drauf zugreifen ordentlich und mal
ein paar sachen von windows ausprobieren was hast du denn für ein problem in next cloud
also in der vergangenheit was mich am meisten gestört hat an next cloud ist dass die ganzen
apps so einen unfertigen eindruck machen dass du so das ist das gefühl dass die haben das
80 prozent fertig gebastelt aber die 20 prozent die das eigentlich zu einem wirklich angenehmen
wie sagt man so schön benutze experience gemacht hätten die haben halt gefehlt da
sieht man zum beispiel daran dass es bis bis glaub sogar letzte version oder so keine
möglichkeit gab ordentlich zu suchen in der notiz ab ich mein allen ernstes man schleppt
drei vier jahre in der notiz ab rum ohne suchfunktion was ist das für ein schwachsinn
und ich bin mir nicht mal sicher ob die suchfunktion das werden wir jetzt übrigens ausprobieren
ich bin mir nicht mal sicher ob die suchfunktion mittlerweile out of the box ordentlich funktioniert
probieren wir gleich mal aus also starten habe ich ja habe ich euch eigentlich erzählt
dass ich dass ich her endpunkt aus dem video gemeldet hat das schütter azubi ich hab letztens
mit dem telefoniert der macht richtig der macht jetzt richtig big brain sachen und
was ich was mich ja persönlich echt ein wenig der hat das video gesehen ja ja da hat das
video gesehen was ich mal was mich ja persönlich ein bisschen beeindruckt hat muss ich sagen
also hätte ich von ihm nicht gedacht er hat gesagt also von sich aus von sich aus das
erst verkackt hat da habe ich gesagt ok nicht schlecht selbst erkenntnis ist der erste
wegen zur besserung sie fallen in der pro version hat ein elastic search stack da hast
du ocr auf dem pdf oh big brain aber ich will eigentlich nicht noch elastic search bei mir
daheim am start haben max ist kompiliert genau so übrigens noch noch eine ganz kleine pains
champ sache die ich jetzt mal los werden muss weil mir das heute echt peinlich war mein
steuerberater hat mir heute eine mail geschrieben hat gesagt hier ob ich hab doch ich hab doch
noch für für für das ja ich hab doch die die ver die rechnung von den versicherungen
und so vergessen die soll ich immer schicken aber ich hatte ja schicke ich ihm schicke
ich ihm per mail und was macht er jetzt der leht im hintergrund das image von next laut
runter und starte das dann können wir es uns gleich angucken so eine halbe stunde später
schreibt mir mein steuerberater noch eine mail und meinte so kann das sein dass sie
die rechnung vor letztem jahr nicht bezahlt haben und habe ich so gesagt nee das kann
doch eigentlich nicht sein das kann doch eigentlich nicht sein und da habe ich mal in meine überweisung
history reingeguckt und habe ich gesagt fack jetzt habe ich echt komplett vergessen normalerweise
mache ich das so ich habe den stapel auf dem schreibtisch und wenn ich die runter wenn
ich die rechnung runter lege vom schreibtisch dann habe ich sie bezahlt aber ich habe ich
habe wohl aufräumen stellz gemacht und was der asubi macht kann ich dir gleich so grob
sagen aber nicht so detailliert weil ich weiß nicht ob er das will und ich habe wohl aufräumen
stellz gemacht habe die die rechnung vom steuerberater runtergeschmissen hab nie bezahlt aber was
aber auch ein bisschen merkwürdig ist dass er das erste nach über einem nach eineinhalb
jahren gemerkt hat dass ich ihm irgendwie 500 euro nicht überwiesen aber ok ist eigentlich
auch würde erwarten dass der steuerberater übersicht über seine eigenen steuern hat
aber gut aber zumindest habe ich ihm jetzt alles überwiesen gut ist so also ja genau
dann ganz kurz noch was der asubi jetzt macht also was er mir jetzt erzählt hat ist das
wird das wird manche leute im chat freuen er kümmert sich um ibm rechner wo kobold
drauf läuft wo sind die kobold fans hier wir haben kobold fans ich weiß genau wir fragen
nämlich immer leute im chat die was von kobold schreiben ja kein witz klingt jetzt als würde
ich den würde ich verarschen wollen nein nein nein er kümmert sich um kobold ibm kobold
rechner allerdings er selbst programmiert wohl kein kobold sondern das machen irgendwelche
china chinesen oder so aber was ich auch witzig fand was er mir erzählt hat ich muss halt
gucken dass ich das jetzt nicht zu spezifisch mache ich habe ihn aus spaß an der freude
gefragt und musste noch struktogramme malen und selbstverständlich hätte ich mit der
antwort gerechnet nein man muss keine struktogramme malen und er meinte ernsthaft doch er malt
noch struktogramme oder sowas ähnliches weil die haben so einen uralt workflow und wenn
die mit ihren mit ihren outgesourcene entwicklern kommunizieren dann müssten sie codeänderungen
per struktogramm oder beziehungsweise sowas in der richtung einreichen und da habe ich
mir gedacht was ist da los kobold was sagen wir ja auch über eine emissionsfreie fahrzeuge
haben und wir müssen natürlich mit den ganzen begleiter erscheinungen selbst wenn du das
jetzt nicht angesprochen hast du fragen die hochstoffe kobold ja uml ist ein versprecher
ja kann jedem mal passieren kann kann jedem mal passieren uml fürs abi ja uml ist auch
pains champ ok hat er jetzt hat er die nextcloud geschichte gestartet was was jetzt ah docke
docke hat er nicht gefunden jetzt bräuchte ich the fuck warum ist the fuck nicht installiert
ei leute meine twitch twitch emotes sind mir schon deutlich zu sehr in fleisch und blut
übergegangen the fuck bräuchte ich jetzt mal gucken ob the fuck das kann nee ich will
the fuck nicht installieren das ist also wenn ich weiß was the fuck ist ich zeig's euch
mal das hat nix mit gachi bass oder so zu tun das ist ein kommando zeilenprogramm wenn
man sich verschrieben hat wenn man sich verschrieben hat da kann man danach schreiben fuck und
dann versucht es zu korrigieren eigentlich eine richtig coole idee achso ich hab mich
verschrieben du schreibst das in uml ja warum nicht uml ist ja schon recht verbreitet ich
meine ich persönlich hab noch nie irgendwas in uml machen müssen zum glück dafür hatten
mir schon mal ein ischikawa diagramm ischikawa auch was ganz tolles das ist der fisch guck
hier der fisch fisch diagramm ist das ischikawa diagramm beste sieht immer aus wie so ein
fisch also das ist kein gag das gibt's wirklich das ist aber nur was für big brain project
manager stonks leute ja aber nix top das gant diagramm leute das gant diagramm ist der
größte pains champ aller Zeiten ich wusste für mein abschlussprojekt damals gant diagramm
machen in ms project leute ich hab noch nie eine so beschissene software ich hab viele
scheiß software was sag ich die mehrzahl von softwaren softwaren softwares ich hab noch
nie und ich hab schon ich hab schon viel kacke verwendet ja aber ich hab noch nie so eine
scheiß software verwendet jetzt ernsthaft wie microsoft project so sieht das glaube ich
da aus ja project libre ok das ist das ganze nur noch in noch schlechter ms project so
ein rotz das ist ich wusste gar nicht dass es das so mittlerweile sogar schon in der
cloud gibt oh pains champ warte mal es gibt es gibt eine teams integration ich muss das
zumachen sonst krieg ich anfälle besser als access nee also ist wirklich das schlimmste
das ist schlimmer als access microsoft project ist wirklich das allerschlimmste so hat er
das ganze jetzt gestartet docker ps was haben wir für eine ip oh nee leute ip liegt schon
wieder was mach ich was mach ich jetzt der chat ist bestimmt schon wieder drin visio
visio ist gar nicht so schlecht visio nee mal ernsthaft leute visio ist doch von allen
office-produkten noch mit das beste ich mein von allen office-produkten was braucht man
da man braucht man braucht eventuell aber nur ganz eventuell excel sonst braucht man
nix wird ist sinnlos powerpoint ist sinnlos was ist eigentlich dabei es gibt sie da eigentlich
mittlerweile ja war not würde ich nicht dabei zählen outlook wenn man excess hat ok lasst
mir gefallen was ist eigentlich alles dabei gibt es gibt es eine übersicht was ist was
ist da alles dabei übrigens das heißt ganz schön office 365 sondern microsoft 365 weil
microsoft gerne den ganzen shit umbenennt so dass es keiner versteht also was haben wir
dabei skype für den arsch wird brauche man nicht excel lasst mir gefallen powerpoint
brauche man nicht one note meinetwegen outlook meinetwegen publisher rots brauche man nicht
excess rots brauche man nicht sway weiß gar nicht was ist rots brauche man nicht skype
for business müll brauche man nicht jammer was auch immer was ist was ist was ist jammer
überhaupt social network und microplogging dienst alter was hat microsoft alles für
rots so brauche man nicht müll sharepoint müll exchange ja wenn es sein muss teams geht
halbwegs planner sagt staff hab sagt power b ok ich wollte jetzt das blöde sein schrott
brauche man alles nicht kenne ich nicht steam nach dem stream alles brauche ich gab es
da nicht noch mehr gab es da nicht noch mehr früher ist das wirklich alles moment moment
ich muss jetzt mal kurz gucken office 2000 was gab es da alles dazu wird excel outlook
powerpoint publisher small business to excel front oh nee so also alles müll excel kann
man meinetwegen verwenden excel ist die meistverwendetste programmierunggebung auf der welt auch wenn
die leute niemals sagen würden sie programmieren was aber viele machen so was ähnliches in
excel und ansonsten eigentlich alles useless ja so also haben wir das hier gestartet blb
cloud so machen wir mal hier darksteam flashbang kann das zum preis jam nee nee sowas mach ich
da nicht mit was machst du präsentation ich bin gezwungen präsentationen zumindest
teilweise mit powerpoint zu machen aber ich will nicht wenn ich es aussuchen kann nehme
ich einfach einen markdown editor und machen pdf draus das ist mir persönlich am liebsten
markdown editor pdf und einfachen pdf im fullscreen machen und durchklicken also brauche kanimation
irgendwelchen fancy fade ins oder sounds brauche man alles nicht ich bin aber gezwungen
die sachen in powerpoint zu machen weil ich mache also wenn ich bei uns auf der arbeit
dinger präsentieren muss dann mache ich das meist anfängt das ja meistens an dass man
das thema erstmal auf der eigenen gruppenrunde zeigt oder vielleicht noch auf einer gruppenrunde
von jemand der was damit zu tun hat da mache ich da mache ich meistens tatsächlich einfach
markdown pdf und zeigt dass ich mache da auch immer gerne emojis und sowas in die präsentation
rein weil ich finde das sieht lustig aus und lockert die sache irgendwie auf ja ich habe
dann immer beispiele ganz groß dieses thinking emoji drin und sowas so das problem ist spätestens
wenn du auf abteilungsebene runde machst dann musst du da bist du gezwungen bei uns
egal wie pains champ ich das ist du musst powerpoint verwenden emojis sind unprofessionell
ja das juckt mich nicht emojis mache ich trotzdem mache ich trotzdem rein du bist gezwungen
powerpoint zu verwenden weil wir haben so eine offizielle unternehmensweite vorlage für
powerpoint und die sind da mega pingelig wenn das nicht exakt so aussieht wie auf da wie
auf der vorlage ich hatte da auch schon öfters diskussion drüber wo ich dann gemeint habe
ja kommt es nicht mehr auf den inhalt an und nein die haben sich auf nix eingelassen vor
allem intern wir reden jetzt nicht irgendwo mehr geht irgendwo hin und hält das vor mehreren
leuten die haben sich dann nicht darauf eingelassen dass man das in einem anderen style macht
das musste dieser ultra trockene 0815 langweilige firmenweite vorlage sein man kennt ja ich
sehe es der chat kann es auch ok admin account also admin account ist admin 123456 guckt euch
das mal an also jetzt mal jetzt mal ehrlich chat ich weiß gar nicht was mit den firefox
entwicklern los ist die wollen mir doch nicht ernsthaft erzählen dieses password wäre besser
als 123456 sogar nextcloud sagt es ist weak das kann überhaupt nicht sein das ist das
weltweit verbreitetste password das kann nicht schlecht sein wir wissen sachen die verbreitet
sind sind gut doch wir brauchen sq light ist best practice genau 123456 123456 best practice
password install recommended apps ok machen wir machen wir einfach mal need help brauchen
ich finish safe admin admin nicht besser geht ja schon mal gut los das geht ja schon mal
gut los ok anscheinend aber alles funktioniert die weiterleitung war die weiterleitung war
einfach nur kaputt ja was auch immer aber guck mal die anderen apps hat er nicht installiert
guck mal ich habe ihm gesagt install recommended apps und die hat er nicht installiert das
lag am docker meinste wie soll denn das am docker liegen ich hab docker host der merkt
da überhaupt keinen unterschied ach oder meinst du weil weil das im docker läuft die
irgendwelche magic haben im docker container nextcloud installiert man ja auf dem eigenen
server sollte man sich noch nicht moment ich muss mal kurz den chat rüber ich kann wieder
den vorlesen also nextcloud installiert man ja auf dem eigenen server sollte man sich
dann nicht auch mit security etc auskennen um den server ordentlich abzusichern das ist
auf jeden fall nicht von vorteil wenn man schon mal ein linux system aufgesetzt hat
ungefähr weiß was man macht aber man muss dazu sagen das ist nicht so wichtig wenn man
das nur intern verwendet die meisten leute machen aber den fehler dass sie der meinung
sind ich muss es jetzt für die welt freigeben und das ist das eigentliche problem also wenn
man wenn man nextcloud installiert bei sich lokal ist es eigentlich vollkommen wurscht
da kann man auch 123456 oder sonst wie was verwenden aber viele kommen dann nämlich
auf die idee und sagen ja ok ich will es jetzt von unterwegs benutzen dann googeln sie sich
irgendwelche anleitung zusammen und dann machen sie solche komischen dinge wie einfach alle
ports weiterleiten auf den nextcloud server in der fritzbox und den dynamischen dns aufsetzen
und dann wundern sie sich warum die krassen hackermans aus china die china chinesen hackermans
am start sind das ist natürlich fail so sollte man es nicht machen hamachi ne hamachi würde
ich auch nicht nehmen also wenn ich meine nextcloud nach außen anbinden möchte dann
würde ich über einen vpn machen am besten tatsächlich das was denn es sagt am besten
wirecard weil es relativ easy ist vpn ist insofern am besten weil da muss man sich einmal
login authentifizieren bei bei euch am router und nur wenn man dann dort in diesem internen
netz ist von dort kann man dann weitergehen und sich da noch zusätzlich anmelden am nextcloud
das ist gut das funktioniert das ist auch relativ sicher gibt es gibt es auch noch
aber was man auch machen kann wenn man keinen bock auf wenn man keinen bock auf vpn hat
man kann auch den reverse proxy davor machen das ist aber das mindeste was ich machen würde
den reverse proxy da kann man dann auch ein gültiges äh zertifikat mit letzen crypt
drauf machen das geht auch am besten das ganze dann aber in so einer art dmz stellen und
ich rede jetzt nicht von fritzbox dmz oder oder router dmz was die hersteller darunter
verstehen sondern der echten dmz also was wo man sonst nirgends wo hinkommt das kann
man machen aber am einfachsten ist es tatsächlich mit einem vpn am einfachsten ist es mit einem
vpn also also wenn ich gar keine ahnung hätte und das wirklich als erstes würde ich überlegen
muss man wirklich von außen auf die nextcloud zugreifen weil ich glaube bei 90 prozent
der leute die müssen das gar nicht und wenn man sagt ja will ich unbedingt machen aus
irgendwelchen gründen man lässt es sich nicht ausreden dann vpn ja und zwei fakte
autentifizierung ist da mittlerweile auch im heimbereich möglich ok nochmal hier kurz
gucken ja ich wusste auch nicht dass es den kram noch gibt naja da steht ja dann auch
direkt im internet also wenn du dir eine vm mietest bei einem cloud anbieter und dort
an nextcloud drauf installiert ist es ja noch öffentlicher als wenn du es bei dir daheim
hast hinter deinem router das würde ich auch nicht machen wenn du sagen wir mal einfach
nur filesync oder sowas machen willst klar dann kannst du dir auch topbox account kaufen
oder sowas hetsner bieten manage nextclouds ernsthaft
aber da ist es hart um in nextcloud nichts zu tun ach doch wep ach tatsächlich ja ok
wusste ich gar nicht ja das kann man sich dann überlegen das kann man sich dann überlegen
aber trotzdem man wird nicht davor oder ich weiß ich die bieten machen die auch komplett
zertifikate und alles also domain zertifikate und sowas für ein dann würde ich sagen kann
man das machen ja amatschi macht ja auch vpn ja aber mit einer software und netzwerk wo
du keine ahnung hast was genau dahinter steht sind amatschi chinesen ist das tencent oder
was ist amatschi lock me in oder oder oder ke kommerz ich hab keine ahnung wem das gehört
aber du weißt nicht was es macht also amatschi zählt für mich nicht als sicheres vpn ja
über das das ist ok das ist ok reverse proxy davor nur port 443 und ein gültiges zertifikat
und am besten machst du halt noch eine sinnige anmeldung wenn du die möglichkeit hast es
irgendwie noch per zwei faktor authentifizierung zu machen wäre auf jeden fall sinnvoll also
die kann es ja dann auch in nextcloud einbauen aber wichtig ist dass man dann reverse proxy
davor macht am besten mit einem gültigen zertifikat und dort schon irgendeine art und
weise von authentifizierung macht und sei es nur basic or ist vollkommen egal es sollte
noch was davor sein weil es gab schon in nextcloud oder ok ich weiß nicht ob es in nextcloud
aber ich weiß dass es beispielsweise in home assistant als letztes ein problem gab dass
man die authentifizierung der anwendung umgehen konnte was bringt ein reverse proxy reverse
proxy bringt insofern was ich soll mal kurz runter ich muss hier muss es hier ich erkläre
es um also ein reverse proxy bringt insofern was dass du dann ein stück software dazwischen
hast was explizit dafür programmiert wurde kontakt mit der außenwelt zu haben auf der
anderen seite hast du halt nextcloud mit pap und sonst was dahinter klar dass es auch irgendwo
dafür programmiert aber ich würde so in einem kleinen stück reverse proxy sei es
jetzt engine x oder kadi oder irgendwas traffic was auch immer was das angeht deutlich mehr
trauen dass das robust ist als so da so da fetten pap anwendung und es gab wie gesagt
letztens erst bei home assistant ein bug das ist pyson das ist kein pap aber das liegt
letztendlich nicht an der sprache da konnte man einfach das login umgehen und überleg
dir jetzt mal zum beispiel nur mal zum beispiel diese pap sicherheitslücke die wir uns vorhin
angeguckt haben ja das was wir uns hier angeguckt haben diese pap sicherheitslücke stellen
dir mal vor die hätte es wirklich in die release version geschafft von pap also ganz
so unwahrscheinlich ist das ganze nicht wenn es zumindest schon mal im master branch im
repo mal angekommen ist was machst du dann was machst du dann dann ist dein nextcloud
komplett offen und das ist sowas das passiert dir mit einem reverse proxy davor einfach
nicht dazu kommt dass das ist richtig was choose my name schreibt dafür ist es auch
relativ easy mit einem reverse proxy davor sich letztendlich kripp zertifikate ausstellen
zu lassen weil das meistens schon eingebaut ist aber das also wenn man sowas wie kadi
zum beispiel verwenden für engine x gibt es auch schon fertige sachen und man kann
auch eine basic autodifizierung davor machen oder man nimmt noch einen plugin was zwei
factor autodifizierung macht also ich würde auf jeden fall irgendwas davor stellen wo
ich mich anmelden muss bevor ich bis zu meinem nextcloud dazwischen kommen ja und deswegen
am sinnvollsten ist eigentlich man nimmt dann gleich einen vpn da kann man sich den ganzen
kram sparen welchen vpn anbieter nimmt ihr gar kein selbst aufgesetztes wireguard wenn
ich es bräuchte oder auch ein vpn dank dir habe ich angefangen mal ein paar smarte geräte
zu kaufen mit denen rumzubasteln mal sehen wie weit ich das jetzt damit treiben meine
wohnung zu wenn du einmal damit angefangen hast wirst du nie wieder aufhören das kann
ich jetzt schon sagen noch nicht und außerdem ist nicht meine aufgabe alles zu wissen was
die haben es sei denn ich soll es promoten oder so ja habe ich ja gerade erklärt ja richtig
ich rede auch nicht von vpn anbietern ich rede von einem vpn was hältst du von selbst
aus den passworts auf dem pittborn kann man machen ich bin immer noch bei key pass richtig
du hast es erkannt korrekt du solltest prinzipiell nie was laufen lassen was zugriff vom internet
hat es sei denn es ist unbedingt unumgänglich nötig du hast es ja der schreike hat es erkannt
du solltest nie etwas laufen lassen wo man von außen aus dem internet dran kommt es sei
denn es geht wirklich gar nicht anders prp achte ne pp kriegste anfälle wenn ich pp machen
muss ok gucken wir uns das ganze mal weiter an den next cloud hast du nicht verpasst haben
wir grad hier hat hat hat sich gerade installiert also was haben die hier schon so schön ist
jetzt so wir haben jetzt ein komisches dashboard das ist neu das kenne ich noch nicht hat meine
next cloud auch nicht ich lokal laufen ab ich habe noch next cloud 18 oder irgendwas
ja ich habe auch ein key pass in next cloud aktuell genauso habe ich es auch und ich
habe das key pass übrigens nur rein lokal gesunken als password manager ok was wollen
die app recommendation deck oh ja kanban style leute herr agile agile ist wieder unterwegs
kann man style deck das brauche ich sofort komm her wie ging das noch mal kann man nie
wie ist das tasks nehmen wenn man das habe ich vergessen ist das ding bort deck deck
so wo ist mein deck jawoll today tomorrow this week also auf gehts hier personal boards
example task jetzt kann ich endlich kann ich jetzt gemacht endlich habe ich mein was ist
das denn endlich habe ich mein privates kann eben ist irgendwie kaputt gegangen endlich
habe ich mein privates kann man bort da habe ich schon die ganze zeit drauf drauf gewartet
dark mode haben die standardmäßig jetzt in dark mode das jetzt auch neu her settings
du mit twitch prime dankeschön für den sub das hältst du von prox mox ich bin noch nie
so richtig warm geworden damit aber das liegt wahrscheinlich daran weil ich mit meinem upunto
surfer auf dem ich die sachen selbst mal relativ zufrieden bin aber das was ich gesehen habe
von prox mox ist das für einen heimbereich echt eine coole sache oder was heißt nicht
nur für einen heimbereich ist an sich eine coole sache der dulexia font was ist dulexia
ist das rechtschreib schwäche oder geht es kann ich nicht high kontrast boah ne lieber so ok
read me ob da read me ach guck mal die haben jetzt markdown editor da standardmäßig drauf ok das
ist ganz praktisch ok jetzt können gleich noch was testen 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 0 soll man testen wie
gut die suche funktioniert testen ob die suche funktioniert 1 2 3 bäm es gibt immer noch
standardmäßig keine suche toxic 15 monat dankeschön für den sub das ist ja high pass
subscription volltext suche muss man mit einem addon aktivieren ok das ist das erste was wir
machen weil das einer der hauptpunkte ist die mich immer mega abgefuckt hat an extra
dass das ding keine suche hat set location india das war jetzt so einfach geht detect location
ok was auch immer ich versuch es gar nicht zu zu hinterfragen
my faff schrimm prime subscription dankeschön für den falscher falscher falscher knopf
dankeschön für den sub wohnort liegt ja in indien aber das war aber seit gestern ist das
eh raus weil ich habe mir gestern für 399 indische rupien youtube premium gekauft für
drei monate was wird gemacht wahrscheinlich mich über nextcloud lustig machen so also wie macht
man die suche an das ist das erste was wir jetzt ausprobieren müssen wo ist das mit der suche ok
wir suchen mal nextcloud enable search unified search how to turn on fulltext search 12 ok das
zu alt unified search find what you're looking for ok ja wunderbar wie macht man das ja das
funktioniert doch schon mal nett haben wir noch gerade gesehen haben wir noch ok moment moment
moment wir probieren das jetzt mal aus angeblich kann man damit ja auch kalender einträge suchen
wo ist mein kalender wo ist mein kalender kalender kalender tasks
da kommt mal deck durch sucht da auch schon mal ein schlechtes ok das ist ganz nice
so wir machen es mal ein kalender eintrag kalender nextcloud ist ehre wie gesagt ich
bin kein nextcloud fan überhaupt gar nicht ok das sieht mit dark seam schon mal echt
gewöhnungsbedürftig aus ok twitch keck weight vielleicht soll ich das richtig schreiben twitch
keck weight so heißt das jetzt der findet jetzt wenn ich nach keck w suche keck weight findet
er das jetzt keck weight das ist schon mal nicht schlecht war so zu der liebe als nextcloud ja das
ist mein problem ich habe noch keine wirklich gute alternative gefunden aber mich nervt
nextcloud und nachdem ich nur sync und kalender verwende gibt es ja potenziell alternativen ich
müsste mich da nur mal drum kümmern ok das finde ich schon mal ganz cool und wenn ich
einfach nur keck suche finde das auch ok nice aber volltext suche geht noch nicht ok wie
macht man volltext suche an findet er dann auch ektai in keck weight in keck weight gibt
es ekt gibt es das wort ektai nicht oder du meinst ich soll mal nach einfach nur nach eck weight
suchen sowas ja findet er anscheinend auch die schlimmste suchfunktion fhc von confluence da
hast du recht confluence ist richtiger pains gemp in ds guck mal ob png und so weiter funktionieren
du hast recht das war das letzte mal das war das letzte mal ja da habe ich mich doch da habe ich
mich doch das letzte mal auch da muss doch auch muss ich mich doch auch drüber drüber weg kecken
das letzte mal dass dass man bilder nicht hochladen konnte ok moment das muss ich jetzt mal
ausprobieren was haben wir hier png jpeg was war das letzte mal was ich was habe ich jetzt
das letzte mal versucht für ein bild hochzuladen was nicht ging war das nicht sogar ein png lego
dankeschön für den snap ich glaube das scheint jetzt zu funktionieren den gif wollen wir mal
gif hochladen gucken wir mal und den gif wie die coolen leute sagen keck wie love gif brauchen wir das jetzt save image s keck wie auf
auch mit sonderzeichen sogar noch hier probieren wir mal aus ob das funktioniert wie kann ich
jetzt überhaupt was kann ich das hier reintracken und trocken gibt es da kein upload button oder
sowas downloads keck wie law love wenn du meinetwo habe ich und wo habe ich das bild gespeichert
jetzt ich habe mich verschrieben wie es gibt nichts anständiges ohne elastic search für
eine volltext suche jetzt mit krepp aus ich meine das ist keine das ist kein index basierte
volltext suche ja aber text suche ist damit saumäßig schnell so lange es nicht millionen von text
zeilen sind und dateien sind was ist ja bei einer privaten installation eigentlich selten ist hallo
ich will was hochladen ok upload geht so schon mal nicht das heißt ich muss in files hochladen
fotos in fotos schieben in fotos schieben fotos und jetzt ist keck wie drinnen nein natürlich
nicht ok gifs kann es nicht aber wenn es kein giftbar fotos kann ist schon naja
das ist ok dass es das nicht kann also ganz ehrlich ich finde die fände die idee gar nicht
mal blöd standardmäßig das krepp zu verwenden ich meine wenn es dann zu lahm ist kann man immer
noch so was wie elastic search umschwenken so also suche wie macht man die suche so suche
moment wir suchen einfach next cloud volltext search
ernsthaft man muss in elastic search installieren wirklich
das ist doch pains champ alter warum
nimm doch eco dms was ist das jetzt was chat chat mir fällt jetzt gar kein vergleich dazu
ein das ist wie wenn einer sagt ich brauche ich brauche zum duschen warmes wasser und jemand
schreibt warum nimmst du nicht deinen wasserkocher so einfach irgendwas was überhaupt nichts damit
zu tun hat ich meine das mag sein dass eco wie heißt das ding eco dms besser ist für dokument
und volltext suche aber nicht desto trotz sollte man textdokumente in so einer lösung hier auch
durchsuchen können so also ok search geht immer noch nett wenn ich das richtig sehe ok top oder
auch nicht top such fulltext search ist in website ok zeig mal her
ok man muss es wirklich man muss wirklich in elastic search installieren das halte ich
persönlich für echt ein versäumnis dass man standardmäßig textdatei nicht durchsuchen
kann und ich will mir kein eigenes elastic installieren für 20 dateien warum macht man
nicht standardmäßig immer die haben sicherlich einen grund dafür aber warum macht man nicht
standardmäßig einen krepp einfach ein stink normaler krepp für leute für 99 prozent der
anwender reicht das und wem das zu langsam ist der kann sich immer noch in elastic search
hinstellen aber einfach standardmäßig keine suche reinbauen die datei durchsucht finde ich
nett nett sinnvoll so ok was kommt als nächstes also suche suche können wir schon mal knicken
das funktioniert nach wie vor nicht das finde ich pains champig äußerst pains champig finde ich
das das heißt was genau ist elastic search elastic im kern und such index also quasi so
was wie google ne nicht wirklich google ist kein suche index oder zumindest ganz viel mehr als
ein suche index elastic search ist ein wie nennt man das genau ist das lucille unten drunter elastic
soll ich quasi lucille frontend lucille ist eine java java library für volltext suche
so und unter der haube ist das eine ewig lange liste aus wörtern eine sortierte liste eine
ganz lange sortierte liste mit allen wörtern die er in deinen textdokumenten gefunden hat
und zu jedem wort wird gespeichert in welchem dokument an welcher stelle das wort steht
dementsprechend kannst du ganz easy suchen nach einem wort und findest dann das passende
dokumenten die passende stelle dazu das ist eine riesen also das ist so die einfachste erklärung
die ich dafür habe das ist eine ganz lange sortierte liste wohlgemerkt es muss eine sortierte
liste sein die leute die informatik studiert haben können wir jetzt bestimmt auch erkennen
warum es eine sortierte liste sein muss hier big brain test machen ja warum ja warum muss
der index sortiert sein prüfungsfrage chat ich sag's euch binar research bei strikes
excellent siste bei search bei strikes weiß bescheid dass du binar research machen kannst
richtig dass du bei der chat ist wirklich manchmal manchmal muss ich echt sagen der chat ist
nicht schlecht manchmal ist der chat schon ziemlich big brain aber das klappt nur durch
die vielen subscriptions die es gegeben hat in der letzten zeit ich weiß noch ich weiß
noch ganz am anfang als ich angefangen habe auf twitch leute so die ersten paar streams
das weiß ich noch da war der chat richtig 3 hat aber jetzt durch die ganzen subs ist
es mittlerweile einfach komplett ex expanet brain low brain so uns ja das ist richtig
du brauchst einen such index sortiert damit du binar research machen kannst und der große
vorteil von binar research ist dass du viel schneller an dem wort angekommen bist was
du suchst als wenn du einfach nur linear durchgehst also immer nur die hälfte nimmst
und wenn du das wort gefunden hast dann hast du auch gleich dahinter die einträge welches
dokument das hat und wo das steht und damit um jetzt noch mal big brain big brain time
perfekt zu machen damit habt ihr übrigens auch die antwort warum alle volltext suchen
pro volltext such implementierung die es so gibt probleme haben mit wildcards an der ersten
stelle habt ihr euch mal habt ihr euch mal gefragt warum warum so viele suchmaschinen
probleme haben mit wildcards an der ersten stelle das liegt genau da dran wenn du die
erste stelle nicht kennst kannst du keine gescheite gescheite suche machen in deinem index wenn du die
erste stelle kennst ist es viel einfacher also wenn in den riesen lange liste aus wortern habt die
sortiert sind wildcard ist sowas zum beispiel hier du suchst worter die mit irgendwas anfangen und
damit lastik search weitergehen und wenn du sowas hier suchst dann kannst du deinen index nicht
richtig verwenden weil dein index ist sortiert anhand des ersten buchstabens aufsteigend und dass
du den index ordentlich schnell durchsuchen kannst machst du beide research darin und dann
funktioniert das und sobald du einen wildcard an der ersten stelle benutzt klappt das ganze nicht
mehr deswegen haben so viele suchmaschinen oder auch volltext suchen und was probleme mit wildcards
an der ersten stelle das einzige was du machen kannst an der stelle ist du gehst den kompletten
index durch und guckst kommt das darin vor so haben wir auch hier ein bisschen was gelernt
so also suche können wir schon mal abschminken was gab es denn sonst noch für sachen der next
cloud die mich immer genervt haben genau dass man in der notizapp nicht suchen kann hat mich immer
genervt mal gucken ob das jetzt funktioniert lego hat bei strike subs subscribes dankeschön für
den sub messes ab der hat es verdient der als jahre hat es verdient der habe ich jetzt schon öfters
positiv aufgefallen ja so also gucken wir mal nach notes quick notes notes ja ja mach mach
next cloud mach ok wo haben man notes notes ja nicht loto leute nicht lotos notes ok neue
notiz 0w 123456 plupp keck weh so perfekte notiz wie ist der titel von der notiz ok wie
die wie die erste wie die erste zeile alles klar 1 2 3 4 passt ok kann ich da drin jetzt
suchen so den titel der notiz werde ich suchen können die finde ich ok nee ernsthaft
ok das springt zur datei nicht zur notiz
wie suche ich denn hier drinnen jetzt wie suche ich denn jetzt hier drinnen
hier hier hat er notes gefunden ok ok das funktioniert das funktioniert so kann man
jetzt kann man jetzt hier wenigstens wenig wenigstens notizen durchsuchen nach plupp
suchen wir jetzt plupp ok das funktioniert das funktioniert gucken wir mal ob das auch
bei längeren sachen funktioniert aber das ganze mal ein bisschen länger in der hoffnung
das kackt jetzt nicht ab und unten unten schreibe keck weight rein zu gucken ob er das
noch findet ok ok ok also wenigstens und das funktioniert auch noch nicht seit der seit
lange wenigstens durch sucht er standardmäßig die notizen das ist doch schon mal ein fortschritt
allerdings muss man sagen wirklich gut ist das auch nicht weil er kann nicht zu der zeile
springen wo das gefunden wurde das heißt man muss jetzt hier noch mal sagen oh nee
nee please ihr habt nicht steuerung f überschrieben oder
please hört auf meine browser shortcuts zu überschreiben
oh nee guck mal ich komme jetzt hier rein ich suche nach keck weight findet meine notiz
und ich frage mich jetzt ja ok wo in meiner notiz ist es und ich kann nicht in meiner
notiz weiter suchen weil sie steuerung f überschrieben haben das heißt ich muss jetzt erst mal hier
oben rein klicken und da steuerung f mal jetzt kann ich nach keck weight suchen ok das ist
tatsächlich sehr suboptimal gelöst das ganze und by the way das ist mein mein hauptsächlicher
kritik punkt annex cloud das ist zu 80 prozent geil und gut gemacht aber den letzten 20
prozent wirken einfach so undurchdacht und unfertig ja auch nicht besser willst du in
der notiz suchen ich natürlich will ich in der notiz suchen zum beispiel ich mache das
so jetzt hat jeder so seinen eigenen bisschen notiz workflow ich habe für die meisten themen
habe ich eigene kategorien in meinem eigene eigene einträge für unterschiedliche themen
beispielsweise habe ich eine notiz für für sagen wir mal video ideen so da steht dann
drinne zum beispiel was weiß ich video für chat machen so so das ding da steht drinne
so und dann habe ich noch eine datei die nennt sich brain dump so und da schreibe ich alles
was mir einfällt rein alles sobald mir was einfällt und ich will nicht das will ich
nicht vergessen weil ihr wisst boomer hirn und sowas schreibe ich hier rein also die meine
brain dump datei kann durchaus noch mal drei vier seiten lang sein oder mehr so und die
gucke ich mir dann manchmal an und schiebe verschiedene themen kann man das übrigens
machen verschiedene themen in die einen passenden notizen für also insofern ich ich denke mir
mal dass das das machen viele ähnlich kann man ordner nein das glaubt es kann keiner
aber du kannst kategorien vergeben irgendwie irgendwo wenn ich wüsste wie das funktioniert
man kann irgendwie kategorien machen wie macht man kategorien checkt das jemand das
geht wahrscheinlich die rechtliche auf notiz geht nicht was sind denn sinnvolle alternativen
zunächst glaube ich weiß es selbst nicht so genau das steht aber demnächst an ja ich
habe keine ahnung wie man das wie man da neue kategorien macht ich habe wirklich legit
kein plan ordner im notes machen auch das ist eine gute idee notes ne die liegen da
so einfach drin wahrscheinlich neue kategorie anlegen ihr vielleicht youtube ok ok und da
wäre ich im leben darauf gekommen da wäre ich im leben drauf gekommen ok so so mache
ich das und selbstverständlich muss ich in der natei suchen können ja notizprogramm ohne
richtige suche kannst du nicht gebrauchen ja chat genau so aber das ist schon mal deutlich
brauchbarer muss ich jetzt mal sagen als das letzte mal wo ich ausprobiert habe aber
immer noch nicht wirklich benutzbar für mich das ist jetzt aber auch nicht wirklich doof
ja island joshi kenne ich weiß ja island joshi heißt und ich und ich island dass du
skandinavier bist das ist nicht wirklich so wild weil man kann andere notizprogramme verwenden
ich mag joblin ich verwende joblin öfters habe ich sogar hier installiert als notizprogramm
das einzig dumme da dran ist übrigens hier wo wir gerade dabei sind das natürlich das
beste was man machen kann auf twitch wenn es sogar mein notizprogramm sagt das also
das sollte man sich jetzt auch mal den druck geben wenn man noch wenn man noch primer primer
ist und irgendwann wird man auch mal hyper subscriber dann das finde ich eigentlich
ganz nice weil das notizprogramm gibt es für mac android windows kann mit nextcloud sünden
können wir beide jetzt mal ausprobieren an der stelle sogar machen wir mal hier neuen ordner was
jetzt mal wofür ist eigentlich das dashboard jetzt gut ok man sieht events und so was ok ok
lasse ich mir gefallen recent statuses glaube das tatsächlich so rechte mehrzahler aha kann man
stracken droppen irgendwie ok lasse ich mir gefallen erscheint mir doch ganz sinnvoll so
ein dashboard zu haben das joblin nextcloud plugin braucht man nur wenn man glaube ich sachen wieder
herstellen will und so was ok wir machen ordner jetzt noch mal test wurscht so und jetzt scheren
wir das ganze damit gut probieren wir mal aus ob wir sünden können es könnte sein dass ich
noch alt nextcloud test hier drin eingerichtet habe wo war das noch mal options sync ah guck mal
hallo wir haben wir haben noch einen test drin test admin 123456 apply im moment test success
back synchronize schauen wir mal ob er das auf die reihe kriegt
was jetzt das ist teilweise painstab kam unter dass die leute lieber google notes und so zeug
verwenden konflikt was zum geier konflikte da kann ich es konflikten der ordner war leer
der ordner war leer wie konflikte da irgendwas ok ich sag einfach sync neu starten ich glaube
der ich glaube der der spakt rum weil ich das geändert habe von der einen nextcloud auf die
andere wegen prime subs das wird sein er braucht mehr prime subs wie kann man wie kann man ihn
denn jetzt überschreiben ich weiß nicht wie kann ich jetzt sagen sync alter sync huge sync
konflikt was mache ich jetzt mit konflikt sonst nie konflikt ok ui des todes ich habe
keine ahnung was ich was ich machen muss excellent perfekt jetzt weiß man sofort bescheid mit was
konflikt ist denn das ist eine zeile das kann doch gar nicht konflikten die rechtsklick auf
konflikte geht nicht das probier schon die ganze zeit ja es ist alles ein bisschen painstampig aber
anscheinend hat er synchronisiert und gut ist ja ich würde es merken wenn es irgendwo eine knopfe
gebe kann es sein notebook ich mach mal ein neues notebook jetzt verschieben wir jetzt verschieben
wir das einfach nach null schieben jetzt einfach alles nach null und jetzt ist es weg und jetzt
wird nochmal neu gesynced was nutzt du denn anstatt von nextcloud ja das steht noch an ich brauche
ordentlich alternativen also nachdem ich von nextcloud von den eingebauten apps nicht allzu
viel halte verwende ich in der regel eh nur kalender kontakte und feilt sind und für feilt
sind habe ich mir was sind es sing sing angeguckt das hat einen echt guten eindruck gemacht bisher
das werde ich mir ein bisschen näher angucken ja und für kalender mal schauen mal schauen
ich habe halt keinen bock auf so ein müll wie outlook privat ich könnte mir einfach
einen kalender server draufhauen aber so offene sachen werden immer immer schlechter unterstützt
weil gerade apple jetzt auch anfängt dass zwar haben sie noch kalender unterstützungen aber
dann fliegt es teilweise wieder raus und das ist echt es ist echt ätzend also das ist halt
der riesen vorteil von so einem gedöns wie sagen wir mal den ganzen google produkten der
scheiß funktioniert halt einfach und ich kann es kann es kein übel nehmen wenn er den kram
verwendet ich persönlich habe halt keinen bock so sachen wie beispielsweise password save oder
so in irgendeiner art weiß auf google zu suchen klar das ding braucht einen master password das
ding ist normal extra verschlüsselt aber es ist ganz einfach wenn die daten nirgends woanders
sind da kann prinzipiell nichts passieren und der beste schutz davor ist sein zeug nicht in der
ganzen welt zu verteilen melkau weiß ich nicht ob das meine anwendungszwecke so wirklich löst
ja ok also das hat funktioniert mit zünden gut also fotos kann weiterhin keine gifts
moment moment moment wait a minute fotos kann mp4 aber keine gifts
oder muss ich das noch irgendwie neu importieren weight keck weight
anscheinend ist echt so kostet extra premium premium primes ab
muss er muss in nextcloud hat twitch in nextcloud nextcloud channel oh guck mal wenn ich twitch
der letzte chancen für nextcloud 19 finde da mein twitch als erstes schiff gif gif
ja ja ist echt so ist echt so wie gesagt ihr wisst ich habe viel bei mir lokal laufen aber
ich kann es halt keinem übel nehmen wenn er den kram verwendet und es hat auch keinen sinn die
leute da bekehren zu wollen denn ganz ganz ehrlich die meisten leute sind technisch halt nicht so
so versiert ja und selbst wenn man die vielleicht argumentativ überzeugt und überzeugen könnte
und sie sehen das ein dass es besser wäre sagen wir jetzt nicht unbedingt ihre privatsten
sachen in die cloud zu legen spätestens mit wie kann ich denn das auf meinem smartphone verwenden
oder wie kann ich denn das auf meinem mac verwenden oder auf meiner windows kiste oder sonst wie das
ist doch mit google sachen ganz einfach wie geht es denn damit und da muss ihnen sagen ja gar
nicht so richtig und das hat schon doof deswegen ich ich bekehr aber auch prinzipiell keine leute
mehr also ich ich habe komplett aufgehört leute da irgendwie bekehren zu wollen das soll jeder
machen was er was er dafür richtig hält weil das problem ist und das kann ja der schlaum was
haben wenn man versucht irgendwie leute zu zu missionieren so nach dem motto hier verwendet
eure eigenen selbst gehostet software blabla ihr seid automatisch immer ansprechpartner wenn was
nicht geht und da habe ich keinen bock mehr drauf und und ihr müsst euch laufend anhören also das
was du mir da empfohlen hast google ist besser oder irgendwie so ein scheißer ja klar aber google
bezahlt halt auf andere art und weise und deswegen mache ich das auch nicht mehr prinzipiell gebe
ich auch gebe ich auch keinerlei support mehr es sei denn mich fragt wirklich einer also direkt
und sagt hier könnt ihr das mal bitte angucken also wenn jetzt jemand ankommt sagt aber ein
drucker geht nicht früher als ich noch wirklich jung war und gedacht habe ich muss jede gelegenheit
nutzen um zu zeigen dass ich krasse heckermann bin oder weil ich mich so viel computer kam
ins interessiert habe wenn da irgendwie einer was erzählt hat so nach dem motto mein neuer
drucker unter windows funktioniert nicht dann habe ich immer gesagt ja hier was hast du gekauft
dann musst du das und das machen oder kannst du mal gucken ja kann ich machen heute kommt
jemand an sagt wachs ich habe einen neuen drucker gekauft schön für dich wenn er nicht
explizit fragt kannst du mal bitte gucken dann mache ich das nicht und selbst dann rede ich
mich immer damit raus dass ich sage ich habe keine ahnung von windows das zieht übrigens
dass das zieht das zieht übrigens wenn man sagt ich habe keine ahnung von windows dann
kommen manchmal da kommen manchmal ein bisschen blöde fragen ja so nach dem motto ja ich denke
du arbeitest mit computer warum kennst du dich denn da nicht aus da kannst du aber einfach
sagen es gibt noch mehr auf der welt als windows das sehen die meisten leute auch ein oder
muss ja auch mal man muss wirklich ehrlich sagen ich habe von windows keine ahnung also
wenn es in die details geht ich bin komplett planlos ich meine ich sitze halt relativ viel
am computer und kann so die standarddinger und finden wahrscheinlich auch die die settings
schneller also die nur 15 nubs aber ich habe keine ahnung von windows wenn du mich fragst
mich jetzt wie es ist msc v dings wie es ist management interface da ich gar nicht ich
habe keinen schimmer ich will das auch gar nicht wissen ne ne ms config meine ich nicht
ich meine ist dieses dieses dieses service oberfläche da und ich meine nicht service
starten stoppen wir heißen das dieses management panel leute ihr seid auf windows mc mc genau
mc exquisite das da meine ich genau also ich kann kein schimmer services ja services kannst
ja aber auch so oft machen ja also wie gesagt habt ihr auch keine ahnung von und außerdem
muss ich dazu sagen dass gerade windows auch mir überhaupt keinen anreiz dazu gibt dass
ich mich damit auskennen will jedes mal wenn ich anfange mich mit ein bisschen windows
sachen auseinanderzusetzen dann ist das ganz ähnlich zu nextcloud du fängst am anfang
an zu gucken und denkst dir so oder hat sich aber einer was bei gedacht oder machst du
das nächste fenster auf und sagt oh nee doch nicht so geht mir das immer wenn ich mich
mit windows sachen näher beschäftigen will und spätestens wenn wenn wenn ich dann irgendwelche
old school dinger hier in der cmd machen muss hört es bei mir auf weil ich bin ein ordentliches
linux terminal gewöhnt das ist jetzt also das ist wirklich absolute zumutung und der
windows realtalk leute der windows prompt der windows prompt ist der ausschlaggebende
faktor warum leute angst vor der kommando zeile haben das wegen wegen diesem scheiß
deswegen haben casual leute und generell leute angst vor der kommando zeile und sie sind
der meinung nur echte hacker mans finden sich da zurecht hätte windows ein ordentliches
terminal eine ordentliche shell dabei dann hätten die leute überhaupt keine probleme
einfache sachen auch im terminal zu machen ich mein vergleicht mal batch und das windows
terminal mit einer ordentlichen linux shell das sind welten dazwischen so was macht das
terminal so schlecht so also also das all das schlimmste an dem terminal kann ich dir zeigen
guck mal guck mal pass mal auf ich kopiere jetzt ich kopiere jetzt meinen emoji so und
ich gehe in meinen ich gehe in meinen ich gehe in meinen linux terminal und copy paste
das emoji das emoji ist da so und ich gehe in das windows terminal prompt und copy paste
das emoji das emoji ist nicht da trash trash dass der beweis schlechthin also einen besseren
beweis kann man doch nicht haben dass es trash ist oder case closed trash mehr braucht man
glaube ich jetzt echt nicht zu wissen darüber übrigens es gibt ja das neue windows terminal
das da das kann übrigens in power shell und cmd auch keine emojis aber ich glaube dass
es in der ubuntu shell emojis kann ja das funktioniert also da sieht man diese encoding
geschichte ist so hart hardcoded in windows dass es nicht nur rein am terminal liegt sondern
eben auch an der shell an sich also ihr seht jetzt allerwichtigste in dem neuen windows
terminal mit wohlgemerkt linux unter windows da funktioniert sowohl in power shell als
auch in cmd funktioniert das ganze nicht was lustig ist dass auch die fehlermeldung immer
anders aussehen ja wofür benutzt man die windows power shell da musst du irgendwelche
windows admins fragen cmd erkannt auch nicht zumindest die version die ich hab kann es
auch nicht leider leider mal gucken ob sie mittlerweile sowas haben schauen wir mal emoji
leute emoji support ist es soweit die gelobte zeit bricht an
warum wer gibt einen daumen runter warum gibt da einen daumen runter drauf aber das
ist abgelehnt es wird keine mochi support geben das war von 2015 wsl soll wohl inzwischen
wsl g heißen was ist lg jetzt neu wayland monka es aber x kann es auch ok das müssen
wir ausprobieren leute das kommt im nächsten stream im nächsten stream kommt wsl x wsl
g warum warum haben die keine mochi support hier warum warum dislike der typ was sind
der desktop das ist der beste desktop eindeutig ich finde sofort alles leute fragt mich was
und ich zeig es euch sofort auf dem desktop irgendwas ja das ist akiles arbeiten post
jam post jam bamm da ist er post jam gefunden instant memes da unten links java s in der
mitte prox xp hier in der mitte max jpeg gibt es nicht freigestellte chico gibt es
auch kein problem also leute uns das chaos einfach ein bisschen überblicken dann ist
das easy wubwurst weiß ich nicht ob es da drauf ist wubwurst wubwurst ist anscheinend
nicht drauf zumindest heißt nicht so ich glaube es heißt einfach nur wurst kann das
sein nicht drauf ja soll es funktionieren ihr seht ich finde alles guter linux desktop
mail klein mit kalender integration eine äußerst gute frage bettel schieb es gibt
keinen so wirklich du kannst an der börd verwenden mit kaldorf das funktioniert ich
würde es aber nicht ich würde es aber nicht wirklich gute kalender integration nennen
aber sondern ist das einzige was halbwegs supported ist immer aktualisiert wird eigentlich
ganz gut funktioniert leider haben sie bei sondern die letzten paar versionen die addons
kaputt gemacht doch doch wsl kann alles mögliche evolution wird auch schon seit jahren ich
mal richtig geupdatet oder früher fand ich evolution auch geil em klein ist super verwende
ich auch em klein richtig poggers aber es ging um linux klein nicht windows klein em klein
für linux gibt es nicht das machen nur leute die zwanghaft cool nach hacker man aussehen
wollen kann ich nichts zu sagen das stimmt echt für euch mal nach dem issue suchen such
mal in steam nach loco motif warum ach ja übrigens ich sollte doch von wem sollte ich
denn vorhin sein sein steam spiel zeigen habe ich nicht gemacht wie heißt es bitte bettel
in die am am eint doch ob ich vorhin sein steam spiel zeigen kann zeig mal her kann
wir uns angucken massif ok video post schon wissen wir was wir für big brain leute im
chat haben sogar auch welche die paint bilder animieren können oder es war gemein es war
nicht böse gemein ich habe nur so nichts erkannt in dem video weil zu pixel ich aussieht
aber wir haben richtig big brain leute ich leute steam wo ist das wo ist das problem ok
müssen wir hier machen ok steam steam ist prognos fack wenn man das jetzt geht ok was
ist das was ist das ist das unreal oder na gut also realistisch betrachtet ist wahrscheinlich
unity weil jeder was mit unity macht aber so wie ich mein chat kennen ist unity zu mainstream
ok ich glaube man spricht es nicht godot aus sondern godot wobei ich da keine quelle
für hab also man kann rumspringen und sich abschießen das level ist ein bisschen wie
dieses alte super dieses alte 2d super diese alte 2d super mario multiplayer da sahen die
levels auch ähnlich aus ist das nicht die schauspieler von wonder woman kann sein ich
weiß nicht wie die genau heißt aber die ist poggers no games to join pippe hands müssen
wir mal im stream spielen ach gar dort hieß sie nicht godot oder gado gado bach alter
ganzen ganzen fake french wörter hier
wie gesagt also thunderbird funktioniert noch am besten finde ich es gibt ein paar stand
alone kalenderprogramme es gab mal ein ganz gutes ist das glaube ich das war ganz nice
aber das gibt seit 2014 wird das nicht mehr entwickelt auch top so typische linux geschichte
bern neues programm kein bock mehr drauf das war ganz cool für kalender sync ansonsten
das sei das problem linux desktop programme sacken zu 90 prozent es ist halt leider so
was ja auch eine gründe ist warum sich warum sich das so schlecht durchsetzt das gute heutzutage
ist dass du 90 prozent im browser machen kannst
teste noch fix den next cloud integrieren mail client kann ich nicht ausprobieren weil
ich kein mail server habe gegen den ich sünden kann zum ausprobieren
em client mit wine boah das spricht nicht gerade für linux desktop wenn man ne windows
software in wine braucht für so basic sachen wie kalender und mail
haben wir ganz davon abgesehen em client ist tatsächlich ganz gut
also em client ist wirklich cool das kann ich an der stelle vielleicht sogar mal zeigen
wir nehmen hier mal next cloud auf fuck wo ist das hier kalender kopieren kopieren
moment wo oh copy kalender address genau wir nehmen wir starten mal den em client der ist
wirklich gut das ist ein bisschen ältere version die ich hier drauf hab
dark theme next import wollen wir nicht will kein mail ich will einfach nur kann kann
man das kann man das skippen mit einfach nur kalender kalder zack admin 123456 finish
ok es hat gut ich weiß nicht warum er zu rep ist aber an sich ist er ganz gut ok wir
installiert einfach mal neu
Habe ich mich vielleicht vertippt bei einem Passwort?
Admin! Come on! Warum brauche ich da für Adminrechte? Dann lassen wir den alten
Failed! Failed! Failed! Warum?
Vielleicht den da?
Okay, okay, das muss er jetzt mal ausverweiten. An sich ist er echt nicht schlecht.
Wo kann man den Kram jetzt hier einstellen?
Menü
Settings kann man bestimmt. Kalender.
Äh.
Was ist das denn?
Kalender. Äh. Accounts. Meine Güte, das ist typische Windows-Crap-Geschichte mit der
Accounts-Admin-Kalender.
Hier löschen wir den mal.
Ja, ja.
Funktioniert nicht, ist aber ganz gut. Natürlich bezieht sich das auf, wenn er funktioniert. Welcher
Low-Brain-Chat wieder hier, Alter.
So, drei, vier, fünf, sechs.
Next. Next.
Next.
Ich glaube, jetzt hat er gesyncht, ne?
Ja, jetzt hat er gesyncht.
Genau. Der ist tatsächlich, der ist tatsächlich ganz praktisch, ne?
Ähm.
Aber im Ernst, es gibt, es gibt wenig gute
Kalender-Geschichten.
Ich verwende Thunderbird mittlerweile für fast alles.
Einfach weil er supported wird, weil er überall läuft und weil er eben regelmäßig Updates bekommt.
So, guck, jetzt habe ich irgendwo den Eintrag drinne.
Ach ne, ich hab nicht gesyncht. Ach, scheiß drauf.
Kein Bock auf das Gefricke.
Ja, es hat mich ein bisschen enttäuscht, dass keine Suche drinne.
Das muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Ich hätte eigentlich gedacht, dass zumindest so eine basic Volltext-Suche mittlerweile schon funktioniert.
K-Organizer.
Das kann man machen,
wenn man KDE-Sachen verwenden.
Man kann es auch so verwenden,
aber es fügt sich am besten in KDE-Umgebung ein.
Das stimmt tatsächlich.
Äh, der ist gut.
Hab ich jetzt gar nicht dran gedacht,
weil ich die Optik und die Bedienung
von KDE-Programmen nicht so mag.
Aber der ist wirklich ganz gut.
Den kann man echt verwenden.
Der kann auch Mails.
Das dürfte somit die beste
Art dieser Software unter Linux sein.
Biete der Integration von Online-Kalendern?
Eventuell mit Plugins, keine Ahnung.
Ich verwende den normalerweise nicht.
Es ist ernsthaft ein bisschen
Paints-Champ auf
unter Linux. Dazu muss man sagen,
unter Windows auch.
Unter Windows sucht mal unter Windows
ein Programm, also mal
EM-Client außen vor.
Das Kalendern kann
Kartoff, Kontakte und E-Mail.
Da fällt mir jetzt spontan
nur EM-Client ein.
Gibt es vielleicht noch die einen oder anderen?
Die Windows selbst eingebauten Programme
kann das nicht.
Es ist alles
äußerst Paints-Champ-ig in dieser Richtung.
Es ist alles Hardcore-Paints-Champ-ig in dieser Richtung.
Es ist leider so.
Und deswegen bin ich auch keinem böse
oder kann ich da keinem das Übel nehmen,
wenn er einfach sagt,
hey, scheiß drauf, ich verwende Google.
So, was ist das hier?
Was sollte ich mir hier nochmal angucken?
Hier, man hat das vorhin gepostet und meinte,
das ist Poggers.
Ähm...
Upuff.
Small Circuit Libel,
Shutdown, Microcontroller,
Save Power,
ja gut, das kannst du machen,
aber dann ist natürlich auch nur nach Timer-Wake-up
angesagt.
Das kann jetzt
gut oder schlecht sein, je nachdem, was man braucht.
Ja,
das ist eine Uhr,
das ist ein Timer-Wake-up.
Das kann man machen, ja.
Wenn man aber
irgendwelche Trigger braucht,
von wegen Schalter gedrückt oder sonst wie,
geht das wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ja.
Moment, der macht doch YouTube-Videos,
das Logo kommt mir bekannt vor.
Ach, CR ist das.
Ja klar, von dem gucke ich sogar ab und zu
die YouTube-Videos.
Ja, natürlich, klar.
Und auch das Logo kommt mir bekannt vor.
Also für Microcontroller-Bastelsachen
ist das echt ein nicer Channel.
Kann mir einer die
Logos-Distribution empfehlen? Ja, kann ich dir
empfehlen, aber du musst mir erst sagen,
welchen Kenntnisstand du hast.
Also suchst du
eher was, wo du einfach
so viel Paketauswahl wie irgendwie möglich
haben willst und dich selbst um
selbst drum kümmern willst
um die Einrichtung oder was suchst
du denn in der Richtung? Es gibt ja total viele Sachen.
Vielleicht suchst du ja auch gar nichts für
einen Desktop, sondern willst
was von Server haben. Also
wie sind deine Kenntnisse und was willst du
damit machen? Kann ich dir wahrscheinlich was sagen.
Excellent Musik hier wieder.
Der Chat rollt wieder.
Musik
Postchamp?
Postchamp? Ah, jetzt hat er was geschrieben.
Das soll funktionieren.
Dev-Maschine.
Debian KDE.
Aber man, Jaro ist dafür echt
das Beste.
Oder, oder,
was auch ganz gut ist, was auch ganz
gut ist, ist Mo Ubuntu. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das
kennst.
Mo Ubuntu ist auch ein super Skin
für Ubuntu, ja.
Beste Dev-Maschine überhaupt.
So, um den Chat zu erfreuen,
um den Chat zu erfreuen,
Qt4M wird gestartet.
Die Qt4M wird gestartet.
Zum Abschluss nochmal.
Also ernsthaft, ich würde dir wirklich Manjaro
empfehlen, auch wenn du,
auch wenn dir die
Arch-Geschichten auf den Sack gehen, ich würde dir wirklich
Manjaro empfehlen. Du kannst entweder
eine fertige
Manjaro Flavor nehmen, wo dann beispielsweise
KDE Gnome i3
oder sowas drauf ist. Aber
ich persönlich mag
mein selbst eingerichtetes
i3
auf Manjaro einfach.
So Leute.
Jetzt.
Endlich haben wir das passende OS
am Laufen. Hätten wir das gleich mal
gestartet, dann wäre heute alles besser
gelaufen.
Und jetzt noch, und jetzt noch
den Hacker-Modus anmachen.
Und jetzt ist alles gut.
Ja, CentOS Server
ist eine super Geschichte, wenn man
Stable Sachen haben will. Wir haben auf der Arbeit
auch nur CentOS, aber als
Development-Maschine würde ich das
nicht verwenden. Ich kann dir mal kurz zeigen, wie das
bei mir aussieht. Wir lassen jetzt
die Qt4M mal im Hintergrund laufen.
Also es ist nicht jedermanns
Geschmackssache, muss ich gleich dazu sagen.
Denn ich verwende einen Tiling
Window Manager.
Oh, ich muss übrigens mal kurz gucken,
Leute. Wollen wir noch eine Runde
Subscriber-Raten machen?
Ich muss aber gerade selbst erstmal gucken,
weil ich nichts übersehen habe.
Matrix HD
hat Subscribed, habe ich übersehen, sorry.
Danke schön für den Sub.
Ich glaube, sonst habe ich nichts
übersehen.
Leute, es geht noch nicht los,
wir raten noch nicht.
Und eine Frage, ob
wir das machen sollen.
Ja, also, jetzt nochmal ganz schnell
zu meiner Linux VM zu kommen, das ist halt nicht
jedermanns Geschmackssache.
Ich habe
einen Tiling Window Manager am Laufen,
das heißt, ich habe eigentlich keine Fenster.
Du siehst, ich habe hier drei verschiedene Desktops,
die ich
durchschalten kann mit
shortcuts.
Was habe ich denn da offen? Oh, das ist doch unsere
Dart, unsere Flutter
Übungssache, ja.
Und, also, ich habe einen zweiten Desktop,
habe ich halt immer einen Terminal drauflaufen.
Auf dem ersten Desktop habe ich
immer einen Browser laufen, auf dem dritten Desktop
habe ich meistens, also, auf Desktop drei,
vier, fünf, sechs, bis sonst, wie habe ich dann
meistens IDE und Texteditors laufen.
Und nachdem das ein Tiling
Window Manager ist, heißt das auch, du hast keine
Fenster. Also sprich, wenn ich jetzt hier einen
Terminal starte, dann teilt sich das
einfach den Bildschirm.
Wenn ich noch einen Terminal starte, dann teilt sich
nochmal den Bildschirm. Ich kann das zwar verschieben
und ich kann das auch so, äh, so
machen, ja, dass man
die, die ein bisschen
anders anordnen kann. Aber
im Prinzip ist es erstmal
jeweils ein Drittel dann.
Du kannst ein Fenster Floating machen
und als Mindrauf verwenden, das funktioniert,
aber das ist halt mit extra Aufwand verbunden.
Aber wenn man sich dran gewöhnt hat, ist es
wirklich cool.
Also ich kann das jedem nur empfehlen, sich das zumindest mal
anzugucken, ob er, aber nicht doch
auch Tiling Window Manager mag.
Das ist wie T-Max nur für Fenster, genau,
genau. Ja.
Nur, dass du es Floating machen kannst, wenn du es
Floating machen willst, ja.
So. Äh, I3
heißt das, I3.
So, und meistens habe ich dann halt hier meine IDE
Sachen auf, ja. Je nachdem.
Je nachdem, was auch immer gerade
läuft.
Und, äh, meine
Evaluation Period
ist ausgelaufen. Na gut.
Genau, es gibt zu I3
auch jede Menge coole Videos, richtig.
Also es kann man sich echt mal angucken.
Ich, mir persönlich
gefällt es unglaublich gut. Ich verwende nichts
anderes mehr. Ihr seht es im Stream.
Immer wenn ich was Ernsthaftes mache, sei es
Programmieren oder ein bisschen Netzwerkzeuge oder so,
wechsle ich in meine I3 Linux VM.
Und die beste Kombi, ganz im Ernst,
die beste Kombi ist,
wenn man, wenn man mit seinem Rechner
viel verschiedene Sachen machen will,
die beste Kombi ist Windows
als Host und
Linux in der VM. Ich sag euch, ich sag
euch einfach, wie es ist meiner Meinung nach.
Weil Linux in der VM läuft
einfach super, gerade wenn man jetzt nicht
ein Gnome oder sowas nimmt, wenn man jetzt nichts nimmt,
was, ähm,
äh, Grafik-Performance
braucht, dass es gut funktioniert.
Ja, ich hab meine Dot-Files auf GitHub,
aber die sind nicht so super aktuell.
Aber es reicht erst mal.
Ja,
ich hab das hier. Wo bloß Dot-Files.
Aber ihr seht schon, ich hab erst vor einem Jahr
zuletzt gepusht.
So. Und
was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Fuck, bin ich stehengeblieben.
Ah ja, genau. Das coole ist halt,
wenn man den Rechner so verwendet,
wie ich das machen will, nämlich ich will
spielen, ich will Video-Bearbeitung machen,
bisschen YouTube-Zeug, bisschen
Grafik-Bearbeitung, hauptsächlich noch
Games zusätzlich spielen und ich will
ein Betriebssystem haben, wo ich den Ruhe programmieren kann
und Hacker-Man-Stuff machen kann.
Und da ist für mich die
optimale Kombination
Windows als Host, Linux in der VM,
denn Linux in der VM
läuft einfach um Längen
besser als Windows in der VM
unter Linux.
Also sprich, Linux in der VM
unter Windows ist besser als Windows
in der VM unter Linux. Dementsprechend
Big Brain,
einfach Windows installieren,
Linux VM machen,
am besten sich vor 15 Euro VM-
oder Workstation-Lizenz kaufen und
man kann Multiple Desktops
unter Windows verwenden und man kann
Multiple Desktops unter Linux verwenden und hat eigentlich
das beste aus zwei Welten
und es gibt ganz wenige,
wie nennt man das heutzutage, so schön
Pain Points
im Stonks
Fachjargon.
Die einzige Sache, die mich persönlich wirklich
stört ist, dass man keine,
dass man den Grafikkarten-Decoder für
Videos nicht unter Linux in der VM verwenden
kann. Also sprich, wenn ich YouTube
aufmache
mit einem Video
und hier
ein Video abspiele von YouTube,
dann braucht das ziemlich viel CPU-Last,
weil es eben keinen Hardware-Decoder gibt.
Aber ganz ehrlich,
da gucke ich das Video halt unter Windows,
meinetwegen, aber
das ist das einzige, was mich ein bisschen stört, aber da kannst du
nichts machen, weil halt die Grafikkarte
nicht in der VM funktioniert, so ohne Weiteres.
Du kannst Virtual Box verwenden,
ist kein Problem, geht, aber
ich finde halt vom Handling
her
VMWare Workstation deutlich nicer
als Virtual Box.
Außerdem ist Virtual Box Oracle
und Oracle ist ja bekanntlichermaßen
Paintchamp hoch 10.
Nee, Hyper-V ist nicht okay.
Hyper-V im Vergleich für
eine Windows, für eine Delungs-VM
als Desktop-Filterisierung finde ich nicht
so gut. So und VMWare kann man
sich, kann man sich relativ easy kaufen
bei den
üblichen Shops, wo es so was gibt.
Und by the way,
QEMO werden die wenigsten Leute
unter Delungs verwenden, die meisten Leute verwenden
KVM mit ein paar
Teilen von QEMO dabei.
Wobei ich bis heute übrigens nicht weiß, ob man
QEMO, QEMO überhaupt ausbricht.
Da bin ich mal
gespannt.
Das probieren wir aus. Das probier
ich glaube ich nicht, das glaube ich nicht, dass das funktioniert.
Auch mal
Video
Video Play
Back GPU
Decoding testen.
Das glaube ich nicht, dass das funktioniert.
Funktioniert.
XCPNG
Das ist Xen, ne?
Joa, nice. Schön, dass du deinen Weg her
gefunden hast. Ich bin jetzt aber auch gleich
oft, weil ich muss morgen wieder früh aufstehen, auf die
Arbeit gehen. Und ich schon.
Boomer schlafen, weil müde.
22 Uhr.
Ja klar.
Ich hab fast alles mal durch.
Also ich hab früher einfach Stock
Ubuntu verwendet.
Als Noob. Danach bin ich
rüber...
Also ja, übrigens das beste an Stock Ubuntu
damals, was ich verwendet habe, war mit
Compiz. Kennt ihr noch Compiz?
Compiz war der Shit, alter.
Das beste, was der Lelungs
Desktop je zu bieten hatte.
Leider ist Compiz
irgendwie dead.
Ich weiß auch nicht warum.
Ja, Compiz ist irgendwie dead.
Keine Ahnung weshalb.
Aber das beste
Wobbly Windows unter Compiz.
Das vermisse ich
das vermisse ich bis heute
unter i3. Man kann
leider Compiz und i3 nicht
zusammen verwenden.
Das wär das geilste. Das wär das geilste.
Ohne Scheiß. Nein, nein, nein.
PCom ist was anderes.
PCom ist kein Compiz Fork.
PCom ist ein Fork von
eh, irgendeinem anderen Composite Manager.
Der kann aber so geile Effekte nicht.
Nein, Compton kann
Wobbly Windows.
Oder?
Nein, kann das nicht.
Also, Compiz
beste, beste,
beste Sache hier.
Wobbly Windows Effekt, Leute.
Das geilste, was der Linux
Desktop jemals zu bieten hatte. Guckt's euch
an. Wobbly Windows Effekt.
Zeigt der das heute nochmal?
Ja, auf.
Wobbly Windows, ii, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Das ist nicht, das ist kein Compiz.
Ich brauch den originalen Compiz
Wobbly Windows.
Wo ist der echte
originale
Wobbly Windows Effekt?
Was sind das alles für Kackvideos? Gibt's da was ordentliches?
Wobbly Windows vor 11 Jahren.
Wisst ihr, was man da gedacht hat?
Vor 11 Jahren, 2010.
2010 hat man sich gedacht,
2011 wird das Jahr des Linux
Desktops.
Und Spoiler, es wurde
nie Jahr des Linux Desktops und wird's auch nie werden.
Hier,
beste Leute, Wobbly Windows.
Da Gatschi
passt sich mir einer ab, wenn ich
Wobbly Windows sehe, Alter.
Guckt euch das an. Guckt's euch
an.
Yes.
Das Beste.
Das einfach das
Beste vom Besten.
Ich hab keine Zertifikate, ich hab mal
irgendwann einen CCNA gemacht vor
10 Jahren, der schon längst abgelaufen ist.
Ja, guckt euch das mal an.
Das nicht weiche
Animation hochziehen hier.
Und das Ganze vor 11 Jahren, oder?
Ja, so weiche
Animation, ja. Weiche
als, ne, das erzähl ich jetzt nicht.
Das sag ich jetzt nicht.
Sonst sind die
Leute wieder triggert.
Die weiche Animation aller Zeiten.
Das wurde ja gar nicht abgeschafft.
Compass wurde nicht mehr weiterentwickelt.
Ach ja, und übrigens,
was auch mega geil war, wo man
wieder krass ist.
Genau, das hier.
Sowas. 3D-Cube für
den Desktop, Leute.
3D-Cube für den Desktop und so.
Da konntest du desktops drehen und so.
Das war richtig geil.
Ich hab auch öfters mal, wenn ich auf der
Arbeit, in der Ausbildung nichts zu tun hatte,
hab ich da gesessen und hab den Scheiß
den ganzen Tag mit den Fenstern gemacht.
Beste.
Ohne Scheiß beste.
Äh,
3D-Cube
Desktop.
Hier.
Okay,
der Dude übertreibt's.
Der übertreibt's hier.
Der übertreibt's mit Compass.
Erstmal Compass-Aufklapp-Animation.
Compass-Feuer-Animation.
Überlegt euch das mal. Guck mal, wie cool
Linux-Desktops damals ausgeschaut haben.
Muss man echt sagen, das hatte was,
oder? Das war jetzt vielleicht nicht
die super minimal Apple-Style-Design,
aber es war schon cool.
Die Aufgieffekte am Start.
Ja, genau.
Das hat sich nie so wirklich durchgesetzt.
Ich weiß gar nicht warum.
Nein, hübsch ist es.
Hübsch ist es nicht, aber es ist cool.
Oh nein, Toss, Toss, geh zu.
Toss, Toss.
Lanz von 2011.
Toss.
Warum geht das nicht zu?
Ich will zeigen, wie er den Würfel zeigt.
Der muss den Würfel...
Exposé-View, der soll den Würfel zeigen.
Der Würfel war einfach Poggers, ja.
So war es hier, auch Poggers.
Wo ist der Würfel? Zeigt mir den Würfel, Leute.
Ich will den Würfel sehen.
Hier, hier, Achtung, Achtung, gleich kommt er.
Da war er, habt ihr gesehen, Desktop-Switch.
Ah, yes.
Das war doch, das war doch
nice, oder?
Du konntest sogar Fenster
von den Dinger tracken und so was.
Das war für mich damals
am...
wo ich Linux läufe, das war das
geilste überhaupt. Und vor allem
ich war der Meinung, Alter, das wird so
richtig abgehen und Linux auf dem Desktop und so.
Und im Prinzip hat dieses Zeug dann
keiner mehr verwendet und Linux auf dem Desktop ist
immer noch Paints-Champ.
Hat damals locker einen Großteil der Rechenleistung
verbraucht. Gar nicht mal so sehr.
Compiz war eines der ersten Sachen,
die so was gemacht haben
unter
nahezu allen
Betriebssystemen. Also klar
hatte Windows
ein bisschen Effekte, Mac auch, aber
in der Art und Weise gab es das sonst nirgendwo
und es war vollständig GPU
rendered.
So.
Muss übrigens ins Bett, Leute.
Nein.
Da fehlt einfach die treibende Kraft dahinter.
Früher ein bisschen mit Ubuntu und ein bisschen
Innovationssachen, kann da was, aber
ich glaube nicht, dass das Linux auf dem Desktop
jemals, jemals was wird.
Ich bin
ganz zufrieden, ja, mit dem, was ich mache.
Dafür ist es gut.
Aber
groß rauskommen wird da
nix mehr.
War nicht aufgestanden, bin halb
acht.
Tja, so ist das.
Ist echt so.
Ja, ich weiß, aber ich mag gerade eh nicht.
Oh, kann ich jetzt nichts dazu sagen.
Gnome läuft in der VM nicht so wirklich gut,
weil Gnome gerne ein bisschen 3D-Beschleunigung
Sachen hat oder halt Grafikkarten nexus hat.
E3, E3 läuft super.
Deswegen verwende ich E3.
E3 läuft super, super
flott in der VM.
Äh, nee. Go ist nicht,
Go ist ein bisschen Painschamp, Minimal
Painschamp.
Also, wenn C++
die Painschampigste Programmiersprache
ist und sagen wir mal
Python, C Sharp
und sowas im
anderen Ende der un-Painschampigsten
Sprachen sind. Also, sagen wir mal so.
Okay, okay, Sekunde Leute.
Ich weiß, ich muss ins Bett. Also, wir haben hier sowas hier.
Wir haben auf der Seite quasi sowas wie C Sharp,
Python, Ruby,
ich kann...
Ich kann nicht schreiben.
Ruby
und so Zeug haben wir auf der Seite.
Und auf der Seite haben wir C++.
Also, das hier
ist Painschamp
und das hier
ist Pogchamp.
Okay. So.
Dann ist Go
dann ist Go
ungefähr da.
Es gibt, also C++ sind wir, glaube ich,
es gibt nichts Schlimmeres als C++.
Java, Java
ist auch hier so ungefähr.
JavaScript ist hier.
Ich finde tatsächlich JavaScript weniger
Painschampig als Go.
C ohne C++
ist auch hier so.
Ich würde sogar C++
ich würde sogar C
entticken weniger Painschampig
einschätzen als Go.
Jeweils für die passenden Anwendungszwecke, ja.
Rust,
ist eher hier
nicht weil Rust schlecht ist, sondern weil
Rust only for
500 IQ big brain Leute ist.
Ruby ist hier. Ruby ist hier.
Ruby ist
unpainschampig. Ruby.
Flutter
Dart, kann ich nichts zu sagen, habe ich zu wenig mitgemacht.
Cobol, also das
was ich gesehen habe von Cobol
würde ich das ungefähr hier ansiedeln, ja.
PAP
Ganz ehrlich, das letzte
schon PAP gesehen, das war gar nicht so schlimm.
Irgendwo hier.
Brainfuck, ja, so was.
Basic, keine Ahnung.
JavaScript ist doch nicht
schlimmer als C++. Perl.
Perl ist hier ungefähr.
Bash
Ich finde Bash ganz cool. Bash würde ich
Bash würde ich
Bash würde ich sogar
da ungefähr
ansiedeln.
Natürlich verschreibt man keine 5000
Zeilenprogramme in Bash.
Lua, boah, nee, keine Ahnung.
Sampler, na das zählt jetzt nicht.
Zu Funktionale, Funktionale Sachen
mache ich da jetzt nicht rein.
Lisp.
Ich
kenne nur Illisp und das ist Painschamp.
Julia habe ich nix mit gerade.
PowerShell
Ungefähr hier, PowerShell ist cool.
Java, auch hier.
Auch so.
Ja.
Vielleicht da, Java würde ich da auch vorne
reinschreiben.
Kannst du versprechen, das ist nicht schlimmer als
C++, jetzt kommt doch an, was du machen willst.
Ich kann sagen, für mich geht es nicht schlimmer
als C++.
Erlang, oh nee, Erlang habe ich noch nix gemacht.
C-Sharp ist
Unpainschamp-ig. Komplett Pogchamp.
Lootguard.
Einfach Google
verwenden.
Wegen dem Key.
Easy, ja.
Da gibt es genug Shops.
So, ich glaube, jetzt haben wir
alles.
C-S-S, na gut,
C-S-S zählt nicht so wirklich, aber C-S-S
ist schon ziemlich Painschamp.
Also C-S-S würde ich mal hier ungefähr,
wenn ihr unbedingt rein, dann würde ich das ungefähr da ansiedeln.
C-S-S ist echt Painschamp.
HTML.
HTML ist nicht Painschamp.
HTML ist direkt bei JavaScript vorne irgendwo.
Oh nee, nee, hör mal auf.
Da fange ich jetzt nicht von an.
Wenn ich da von anfange, dann komme ich gerade
ins Bett.
Ist die Auflistung
empirisch belegbar?
Ähm,
ich würde sagen, wir müssen da mal dringend
Studien zu durchführen, ja?
Abab.
Okay.
Painschamp.
Proggers.
Swift?
Hab ich noch nichts mitgemacht?
Großartig.
Nein, bin ich nicht.
Auto-Hotkey.
Da hab ich auch nicht viel mitgemacht.
Das ist aber auch
mittel, mittel, mittel,
mittel Painschampig.
Abab, was weiß ich,
wo Abab liegt, Alter.
Okay, Leute.
Ähm,
ich, nein, nein,
hör jetzt auf, ich geh jetzt ins Bett, machts gut,
wir sehen uns, bis morgen wahrscheinlich,
bis denn, see you.